this is Jocko podcast number 384 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
I was studious by nature and I had read
considerably about the war I knew that
the careless way in which we fired our
guns and dropped bombs in France was
hurting lots of people
the average time in which a British
soldier was still able to fight after he
landed in France was three months
killed wounded gassed captured something
put them out of action in an average of
90 days
so I enlisted with my eyes open
expecting to get killed but hoping to
have done more than my part before I got
mine
I was young enough that I had a desire
to be something
great when I died so that my parents
would receive a posthumous reward of
some sort of metal and know that Bob had
died bravely
but I did have ideas about the way I was
to die if I must and none of these ways
was with a Bayonet or a knife in my ribs
I had an antithepie toward Cold Steel
entering my body and trained hard to
learn all I could about bayonetwork in
fact all through the War I trained just
as hard as I would for an important
athletic contest
I often thought that might be out in no
man's land or meeting some form of an
attack where I would come upon
hand-to-hand fighting with a German
and he might be one of the great old
German strong men of whom I had read
I knew that they would have much more
strength in my slender frame possessed
and in order to remain among the living
I had to acquire skill to win such a
battle
I not only worked hard during the
training time but I talked to every man
I met who had experienced hand-to-hand
work at the front
so that I could learn
any tricks there were
these tricks did save my life later in
the war
I must explain here that although I
expected to die in the war I knew that
one Army beat the other by greater
courage or greater efficiency in
fighting the side that inflicts the
greatest casualties on the other would
ultimately win
therefore I intended to sell my life as
dearly as possible and see how many of
the enemy I could take with me or send
before
I never got careless I always had my gas
mask I always carried a shovel and pick
with me throughout the war some men
became tired and threw their entrenching
tools away but not I
I was the champion Digger of the
American Army every time we stopped I
dug a hole we didn't know when we
stopped or whether it would be five
minutes five hours five days or five
weeks
and as long as we were there I improved
my little dugout
and I can tell of many cases in which
this digging saved my life
I owe much of the fact that I am here
to careful training
and superb physical condition
and that right there is a little excerpt
from the book I remember the last World
War which was written by Bob Hoffman
it's a book we covered early in the
podcast podcast number 27.
so that's like seven years ago and he
wrote another book called How to be
strong healthy and happy there's a guy
that fought in the first World War
and he fought in the trenches in the
first world war and in those books he
explains over and over again the
importance of physical activity of being
strong and being able to lift weights
and being able to do pull-ups and being
able to run
and in his books
he actually complains that men were
getting weak
this was in the 1930s by the way he goes
on tirades about how men spend too much
time watching Motion Pictures
they eat too much bread biscuits pies
pastries and donuts
that through physical training you could
condition yourself to obtain pleasure
from overcoming and defeating problems
and obstacles
and that this would give you greater
confidence in your own abilities
by the way like I said these books are
written in the 30s Bob Hoffman spread
the word as widely as he could
in his life he founded the York barbell
company which is still around today
he started the he started a whole media
arm which in those days meant he started
muscular development magazine he founded
the York oil burner Athletic Club
that's what he was going that's what he
was doing and we'd be in a much better
place
I think if people actually listen to Bob
Hoffman but
they didn't
and our health as a country has
continued to decline but
in my old job in the Navy we were always
searching for ways to
get stronger get faster get healthier
get better and
we tried when I first got in the the we
tried what our training was which was
calisthenics and traditional physical
training military physical training we
tried
some weird combination of triathlons and
bodybuilding
we played around with Olympic lifting
and power lifting maybe even a little
gymnastics
some guys
really pushed to see what worked and
what didn't what could get us ready for
combat that was that was what we were
looking for what would get us ready for
combat
and what that means is there's an
infinite number of things that combat
can bring
so what can we do to get ready for just
about anything
and people were trying to figure that
out one of the people that was trying to
figure that out was a guy named Dave
Castro he's a seal who deployed many
times overseas
deployed to Iraq and Afghanistan
he wanted to be strong wanted to be fast
wanted to have endurance wanted to have
explosiveness and he over time found a
path for physical fitness and he's LED
kind of like Bob Hoffman he's led many
people down that path including many
seals many Special Operations Personnel
conventional soldiers
Marines law enforcement First Responders
and on top of that just like Bob Hoffman
was trying to do he's done that with
every day civilian human beings that
just want to be better
and it's an honor to have him here with
us tonight to talk about his experiences
and Lessons Learned Dave thanks for
coming down man Taco thanks a lot for
having me it's an honor
um I'm excited to dive into all of these
topics that was a great Intro by the way
that's a powerful book I definitely am
going to pick that up and and dive into
it yeah it's an awesome book and his
other book over here which is called how
to be strong healthy and happy is this
one is just combat it's literally combat
I was looking at it yesterday it's
combat till the last page the last page
like people are getting killed and then
it ends this book though how to be
healthy uh strong happy and healthy is
is more of a manual and it's very
interesting you know some of the quotes
I pulled out of both of those but it's
incredible
that
people have been trying to figure this
out and trying to teach people about
this for so long and that's what made me
bring bring that's what made me think
about those books because this is what
you've been trying to do for the last I
don't know what it's been it's been
15 years something like that almost 20.
almost 20 years you've been trying to do
this
um
let's start at the beginning let me let
me say this yeah before even the
beginning I want to talk about this and
and the path and his journey and how he
was searching for the best way to get
basically strong and fit and ready for
combat and exactly what you were saying
not a lot of guys acknowledge
well honestly prior to CrossFit The Way
We Were training you you hit it there
was triathletic triathletes people
biased towards that there was
um guys who biased towards physical or
um just body weight stuff pull-ups
push-ups and then you had the
bodybuilding type and every one of those
was sort of done in isolation and people
grab especially once you got to the
teams people gravitated towards what
they wanted to do I was a runner and
that's what I excelled at in Buds and as
I went to different teams that's what I
was good at so I kind of followed that
stayed away from the heavy weights I'm a
smaller guy and so and you know what's
interesting I don't know if your
experience is different but mine on the
East Coast I hardly saw anyone doing
Olympic lifts
um back squats and deadlifts saw a
number of guys who especially football
players or guys who are athletic who did
that but the Olympic lifts I don't think
I saw many people doing those at all
yeah I would when I mentioned gymnastics
the only reason I got to throw that in
there is because my commanding officer
at Seal Team one when I was a brand new
guy
he was a gymnast yeah and so he he's the
first guy I ever saw doing muscle ups on
the pull-up bar remember that little bar
pull apart still team one it was a
really nice heavy pull-up bar and I was
a new guy and I'm out there watching him
going oh damn like I need to up my game
yeah and he's another dude like he was
jacked yep and and I used to think this
dude's getting his uh his khakis
tailored his uniform was tailored
because he had no v-body in his art his
sleeves real tight he was jacked but he
was doing muscle ups and I remember
thinking what is that yeah and then
starting to try and figure out how to do
it on a bar never thought of rings never
never would have thought of rings until
like until the CrossFit stuff started
come getting to the teams and I'm I'm
sure we'll get to that but so then I so
I've started deploying and I went to
Afghanistan and on my first trip to
Afghanistan
um we started doing combat Ops and in
preparation for them I was running
because that's what I defaulted to I was
a runner and you'd insert hiko over
these mountain ranges or hike over these
terrain features you'd get to Target and
then you'd go really hard and then you'd
come out insert or X fill out and go
back and I felt like on Target and I
wasn't I didn't have enough power enough
kick I didn't feel like I was fit enough
and so naturally I was like okay I need
to run more I need to increase
um I need to increase the amount I run
and at Bagram we had a there's a loop
around the entire base and we'd run it
you'd run it once it was four or five
miles it's like naturally I need to do
it twice and so I started doing that
more and I still didn't see much
improvement at all on target so I was
intrigued by that and I was doing a lot
of body weight stuff too so combining
them and thinking how can I get the most
out of Fitness or how could I take this
to the next level
every one of us in the teams has a
passion it sounds like early on your
passion a passion almost even outside of
of the the work but related to the work
sounds like you got into Jujitsu yeah I
did sure enough mine was rock climbing
so early on when I was in the teens I
got into climbing and I just went all in
and that's what I really enjoyed doing
on my off time I'd go climbing I was a
lead climber all types ice climbing rock
climbing bouldering big walls in
Yosemite I just really went all in on
that aspect of of the job and on a
personal level well Mark twice he was
this famous climber and he had this book
called Extreme alpinism and he talked a
lot about the way he trained and the
alpiness the alpinists um per mindset
towards going super light and super fast
in their routes and in their climbing
that really resonated with me I saw that
and I was like okay that's that's
similar to our mindset and what we're
trying to do we're always shaving ounces
and trying to go as light as possible on
our missions and so that aspect
resonated with me the way they
approached their climbs and the way they
tackled them once they were there and
this was specifically Mark twice this
was a guy these guys were Radical what
they were doing they were insane they
were climbing Peaks that would take guys
four or five days in 48 hours to 24
hours straight because of their
philosophy of super light and super
aggressive and fat light and fast light
and fast they would they would set the
records on all these routes and a lot of
it it wasn't just for the fact of doing
it quickly it was for safety too the
faster you get up and down the mountain
the safer you are ultimately
um and I read this book he had it was
extreme albinism and he talks about his
training and it was long slowed LSD long
slow distance stuff go out for three
hour bike rides go out for two hour runs
and and that's how he prepped for all
these Endeavors so that's in my mind I
was like I need to do more of that to
prep for this stuff
get back from a deployment and we were
able to hire him out to do some training
him and his staff and we went to
Yosemite and on a training trip we were
doing some climbing with some of the
other Climbers on the team and a number
of his world-class climbers
I said hey Mark so tell me this is that
dinner in the cabin after a full day of
climbing tell me about your training
tell me about the long slow distance
stuff and he said I don't do that
anymore and I go I was blown away
because like I studied his books and he
was an icon to me I'm like what do you
mean you don't do that anymore because I
do something different he goes I do
CrossFit it's this program that's
created by this guy in Santa Cruz named
Greg Glassman and I go well what is it
and he's like it's body weight movements
it's pull-ups it's running it's cleans
it's deadlifts and I was super skeptical
because I'm the skeptical guy by nature
and when you look at Mark twice he's a
I'm a small guy he's even smaller than I
am he's he was probably 150 five foot
nine five foot eight and I was like okay
cool this all sounds really cool but
coming from him I don't know if you know
this is the right thing for a seal who's
deploying to Afghanistan and I heard him
I listened I started researching I
started looking into CrossFit I started
looking at all the uh the website and
all the journal articles and it it was
incredibly intimidating especially
because I didn't grow up with um the
Olympic lifts or powerlifting really or
any of those movements so the movements
I was like man I don't even know if I
can do any of those movements I saw
stuff like air squats I'm like I can do
that I I looked at a lot of things I
could do and said okay it doesn't seem
too bad but I didn't buy it and
especially because his he was the guy
who um exposed me to it so I sat on it
for a while researched it actually ended
up deploying again and even on
deployment in the room where we had
internet I was sitting at one of the
computers I'd sit at the computer every
night and check out the workout of the
day still not what year is this this is
uh three four
oh 304 or 304 cool still not having done
it myself yet we had a guy who was
really fit on the team
and he came in and he sat down next to
me and he said what are you looking at
and I said oh this is CrossFit you
should check it out he's like oh what is
it and I start telling him it's this uh
this workout that combines all these
different features and elements and
they're really fast and and it gets you
really fit I kind of faked him out and
gave him the impression that I was doing
it so he's like awesome I'm gonna dive
in he started doing it and I started
From Afar just watching how it was
affecting him and the results he got
from it and he fell in love with it and
he saw a lot of results from it and we
came back from that deployment and I
still hadn't
um laid the plunge and decided to do it
so later I ended up breaking my ankle in
training so that delayed the uh the
effort deployed to Iraq and on day one
of being there decided all right I'm
going all in and I started doing it and
it I and the thing about it as you know
uh Iraq versus Afghanistan in terms of
op Tempo in Afghanistan missions took a
little longer to develop at once a week
well maybe twice a week at the max at
the time we were doing missions Iraq
you're going out every night and so you
have the potential to go out every night
and so we were on one of those every
night type of situations go out come
back hit the workout of the day from
crossfit.com go to bed wake up at night
because we're in a nocturnal rotation
and and just repeat and I started seeing
great results and I fell in love with it
interesting story there
one of the other guys I was with he saw
me doing it and he's like hey I think I
want to uh try it I go all right when
the next workout pops up let's do it and
so the next day we were just following
the workout of the day the workout that
popped up was a workout called Linda
three bars of death so it's ten nine
eight seven six five four three two one
of deadlift like one and a half times
your body weight bench your body weight
and clean three quarters of your body
weight and it's really one of the harder
Crossfit workouts and he did it and as
his first crossfit workout ever on
deployment and I think he even tried
going RX I had to scale because those
weights at that time were too hard for
me to do even though I was developing
strength so that was that was how I got
into into the fire but I researched and
watched for a long time before actually
taking the plunge yeah
um well damn you jumped right right you
skipped the whole thing I was going to
start with which is like where were you
born I'll go there we can go there right
now
where were you born I was born in um
San Jose California 77. and and were
your parents what'd your parents do my
dad
um he ran a trucking company okay and so
he had a truck yard in San Jose and when
I was uh in about 84
85 we moved from San Jose to uh Aromas
where he bought a 65-acre property and
that's the the home of the CrossFit
Games many years later but he moved us
out there to consolidate basically his
Trucking operation and
um the the house so it was all
co-located and um even now so that's
still in the family both my parents have
passed my brother and I we own that
property and that's where again the
games have been held multiple years and
I spend a lot of time there it the the
place means a lot to me it's the
CrossFit Ranch yeah that's what it's
known as yep
and was your dad in the military was
your mom in the military no neither of
them were in the military none of no uh
actually that's not true my um
grandfather from my mother's side he was
in the Korean War okay yeah so he had
military experience and you know as a
kid growing up he had his M14 that he
was able to M1 yeah and um
underneath the bed and we'd pull it out
and look at it and he had his ribbons on
the wall so there was def that was
definitely influential but in my inner
circle that very little uh military
influencer connection and you mentioned
that you when you were growing up or you
mentioned that you were a runner was
that which is the sport that you did
when you were in high school and
everything well no so the interesting
thing about the running is um
I didn't discover that I was a decent
Runner until I decided I wanted to be a
seal and started following the buds
warning order the buds warning order was
this online packet that told you how to
prepare for Buds and it had like
um running in PT a running in PT program
that escalated in in difficulty and once
I started doing that and that was right
after I graduated from high school I
realized I was a pretty decent Runner
and I thought I wish I would have ran in
high school here's what I did in high
school I was on the football team for
all four years I might have started one
game I tried out for the basketball team
I didn't get picked I um and I tried
really hard at these things to me to to
make it to the team and like I put a lot
of effort into football and I also tried
dabbled in wrestling uh that I just
didn't dig it was into martial arts
really into like martial arts I did um
escrima so Filipino stick fighting I did
a traditional karate traditional
Taekwondo
um UFC was like I remember watching the
early like one and two and three and
those were coming up in those days into
boxing as a youngster just um training
on my own the the martial arts formal
training the boxing on my own the lack
of success that I had in high school
sports is a big part of why I decided I
wanted to become a Navy SEAL how did you
hear about the SEAL Teams so the summer
after I graduated from high school 96 I
went to the movies with my girlfriend at
the time we watched the movie with Sean
Connery and Nicholas Cage called The
Rock
and uh you know the story in that movie
a group of Marines take over Alcatraz
and then they call the baddest
in to come save the island
to save the nation from the nuclear
weapons they have and these dudes
Michael Bean like that was like the
third or fourth movie he'd been a
ceiling he comes in he's the commander
and it's these guys in all black and
then they have all this cool gear then
they insert dirt in the water with their
little mini submarines and the dude
comes up out of the water with the MP5
and I'm like man these guys are badasses
and then they come through the sewer and
come out of the shower and the Marines
waste them didn't matter I was already
heavily influenced by the black gear and
how cool everyone was so I left that
theater and I started researching
everything I could about Navy Seals and
I started watching all the movies read
all the books and the thing that kept
returning in what I was consuming was
the fact that the training was the most
difficult training in the military
and at this point I had been accepted to
Cal State University Monterey Bay so I
was going to college and my parents
really wanted me to go to college but
that notion of the toughest training in
the military
something happened I went
I wonder if I can do that and that was
it once I said I wonder if I can
do that I was like I need to chase this
and I need to figure it find out if I
have what it takes to go through this
training and become a seal and and again
I had this burden of feeling like I
didn't accomplish months much
athletically in high school and I was
like and and here's the thing and we
know I'm saying accomplish much athletic
athletically buds is not athletic you do
have to be in shape but Buzz is a
hundred percent a mental test I would
learn that later I didn't realize that
at that point but um so I told my
parents I wanted to do and they're like
no way you got to go to college
and so I said okay so I started school
about two months into it I had this
other realization I thought
if I don't do this now if I finish
school because they said hey finish
school and then do it after that
I thought I might not ever do this life
will change life can change so much if I
don't do this right now I said to myself
and it's pretty funny when I think back
of it even being 18 19 at the time that
I was able to for whatever that I
thought this I've I thought I don't want
to be 30 years old and looking back and
saying I wanted to be a Navy SEAL at one
point I'm like I need to do this now I
dropped out of high school and our
College sorry and told my parents I'm
enlisting and I enlisted
and I and that that for me even that
moment that less that life lesson that
that's been something that's meant a lot
to me and I I even advise people or help
people with that just like hey sometimes
you have to Chase the Dream because if
you don't if you delay it there can be
so many other things that get in the way
of it ever happening and you don't want
to have that regret but here's the thing
you have to be really measured and
realistic about that because I think
that especially with social media and a
lot of the messaging there's a lot of
the chase your dream and all that
that's really surface level and shallow
but there's a big process you have to go
through in your mind and in
understanding what it represents to
chase it if the timing's right if you
should rather than just recklessly
Chasing the Dream yeah because the
reality is of every you know guy that
goes so I'm gonna go for it 80 of them
don't make it yeah it's probably more
than that too like exactly the people
that actually make it to buds don't make
it so you don't have a really good
chance of making it did you uh what kind
of prep did you do like so you're doing
this buds warning order but the buds
warning order was an online uh program
that the nsw put out so this was 96.97
internet was obviously around then in
the early stages and they had built out
maybe not the early stages but it had
been around for a number of years they
had built out
um a recommended training protocol for
Buds and you did it stuck to it I stuck
to it I'm that type of person like if
there's a training for an event or a
training protocol that the event's
putting out you probably should take a
look at it and follow it because they're
probably trying to set people up for
Success yeah so yeah I followed it at
the time so when you get to buds or how
was boot camp was it a shock to your
system were you like no this is what I
signed up for or good to go I'm down
with folding underwear and boot camp was
a massive shock specifically culturally
uh I grew up in California and I
remember going through the lines and I'm
like hey what's this thing called grits
and like I had never even heard of grits
and so like I had never really left
California or that area my entire life
and so it was a big cultural shock for
sure
one other interesting thing about that
period too especially once I went to
buds growing up in California growing up
in that area growing up hispanic as a
Mexican when I was applying for colleges
the messaging and everything was about
hey make sure you tell them you're
Hispanic it's going to help you get in
it's going to help you it's going to
help you get admission it's going to
help you advance and I was like okay
cool I didn't know any better I was a
kid once I got to the Navy to the
military once I got especially once I
got to buds I saw that that didn't
matter at all it didn't matter what
color you were it didn't matter where
you were from What mattered was
performance and the standards that they
put out and that you met them and that
you worked hard to accomplish those
goals so a little shock to the system
and you get done with that you check
into buds so what year is it when you
get to buds so uh late 97 so graduated
in 98. okay what was strengths and
weaknesses going through buds I think my
strength was being um
kind of middle of the road like I wasn't
I didn't excel at anything
um I was good at running so that was
definitely a strength um like you never
fell back on runs never fell back on
runs uh not good a weakness was swimming
for sure how about just general comfort
in the water General comfort in the
water so even now at this stage I'll say
hey I'm not a fast swimmer but like
especially because of the training in
all the years I'm really comfortable in
chaotic environments in the water so
being comfortable in the water that was
trained into me through through the
training I didn't know I was comfortable
in the water prior to buds but um oh and
I did sort of even back up I swam a lot
and the buds warning order had a
swimming protocol I swam a lot to get
ready for buds because I wasn't a
swimmer through high school and as you
know the difference between someone who
has a swimming background and someone
who does not who goes to training like
that it's massive it's mad quick story
on that we're swimming if you don't mind
um we're swimming at one once I was team
many years later around an island in
Puerto Rico we were afford we pushed to
Puerto Rico for a little um
Outpost I want to say deployment but
it's silly to say that we deployed to
Puerto Rico
um and so there was an island off our
base few hundred yards away and we'd
swim around it we'd launched from The
Shore swim around it and come back as a
as a platoon and I'd been swimming a lot
at the time because I wasn't a good
swimmer and I was like okay I want to
train and I want to get better and I
want to represent myself well on these
Evolutions we take off and as you know
in the teams most of the swims at least
we were doing on the East Coast were
with fins we're going around the island
and I'm in front of everybody and I'm
like all right cool the training's
paying off and one of our officers
forgot his name he was on the other on
our sister platoon he starts slowly
passing me and I'm like this is
awesome I've all my work's paying off
because he swam in college and I'm in
front of him and as he passed me he had
no fins he had no fins on and I was like
all right that's the difference right
there we all had fins on he had no fins
on and he uh he came out and beat
everybody on the on the swim anyways
back to strengths and weaknesses so
um I think it was this
my mind said the way I approached it I
think really
um was a strength ultimately obviously
because I made it through and just it
sounds so silly even when I say it but
it is powerful and how to make it
through there was a point where I woke
up and I said
I still have five months of this
I still have five months of all this
we're going through and like
how am I gonna survive this and I
stopped thinking about how much time we
had left to go through it and even in
workouts or endurance stuff I do now
I'll still sometimes stop thinking about
the the total duration just think about
what's in front of you so at that point
forward all I thought about was um just
make it to the next meal
and just make it to the next meal and
that that was I had to think sitting in
the cold sitting in the surf all right
the next meal is going to be in three or
four hours this isn't going to be that
hard
one other interesting thing about when I
got there I was one of the younger guys
in the class at 1819 I was paired my
roommate was a 32 year old Force Recon
gunny sergeant
yeah and so talk about opposite ends of
this spectrum and talk about a culture
shock and we became really good friends
and spent time together and you had this
guy who was a Hardcore Marine X-Force
Recon ex-special for and I had just
watched The Rock a year earlier so I
knew everything about Force Recon and um
so his presence was also really seeing
how he handled everything and how he's
just quiet and professional and how he
conducted himself was a huge influence
and I I don't think it was by design
that one of the younger guys in the
class was put with someone like that
through to be a roommate and um you know
when I was not
um
let's say behaving professionally as a
young sailor he was there to straighten
me out
I had a like an E5 roommate who same
thing like he was just older had been
around
and then he quit
that's what I thought you were going
around this guy this guy stuck through
that's awesome he made it through uh did
you get rolled back for anything
no I made it through my first time and
um just again like the middle man just
making it through every evolution uh
didn't get injured and didn't get
performance rolled if anything I was
very close at multiple times getting
performance world for
um swimming but how about like pool comp
and stuff were you good to go yeah I
made it I mean I might have failed once
or twice but never um like where you get
to the limits of how many times you can
fail yeah it sounds like you
were the same as me like I didn't well
you sound like you were a better Runner
maybe I was a better swimmer but I
didn't win anything never ran never came
close to winning a run never came close
to winning a swim never claimed close to
winning an obstacle course but I also
never got rolled back for anything yeah
I failed pool comp and then I passed it
so being that what they now call I guess
they call it the gray man now which is
like you're just there's a lot of people
in that class and if you're kind of just
blending in and you're getting the job
done yep it's kind of a nice place to be
you know because as you have the loud
Mouse you have the guys that stand out
for being characters you um have the
guys that get a lot of attention for
performing poorly at everything I just
tried avoiding those extremes I just
tried staying away from that like I had
a I had to do my job I don't want too
much attention from the instructor's
good or bad could you win the runs would
you win a Four Mile time John we had
some fast guys yeah like fourth or third
yeah exactly I wouldn't I couldn't win
them we had some really fast guys
everything I had to I had to put out
really hard to pass everything
everything I did I kind of had to put
out hard there was no crew I had no
cruise I don't think other than
life-saving life-saving I was not
worried about I'm like I'm gonna kill
the whoever my instructors I'm gonna
fight him so I was kind of fired up were
you big then no I was 174 pounds when I
checked into buds I was 185 pounds when
I graduated what about you you remember
what you were in the 50s okay yeah I was
smaller than even yeah I was just
hostile you know I was good at like I'm
gonna I'm gonna fight this dude I saw it
as a fight so I think that helped me
uh so you graduate from Buds and then
where you go I go to the east coast and
I spend all my time
um pretty much on the east coast and
what team did you start at you
so this is funny and this is going to be
a good conversation I've kind of drawn A
Line in the Sand with myself as a seal
professionally or even on the outside
now where like I don't like talking
about the numbers I don't like talking
about any of that stuff because when I
was working for CrossFit it was um when
I started working for CrossFit I was
still an active duty seal and there was
a couple other seals around and I saw
how Glassman and the media team kind of
wanted to I wanted to say take advantage
but highlight right and I was like hey I
don't want my identity to be built
around me as a seal or my exploits or so
they they really listened to that and
they did a really good job of not
highlighting so I kind of I told myself
at that time hey that they a lot of the
experiences I had and the teams I went
to and the things I did I'm not going to
talk about especially as I started
seeing once social media came around how
met much guys did and how how many lines
guys cross now so
the thing I'm trying to be at this point
I still meet people in CrossFit who come
up to me and say hey I've been following
you for 10 years and I just found out
you're a Navy SEAL and I'm like
success you did good yeah I'm like
success and so at this point I I
have a i some some of the units I've
been at I still have guys I still get
invited back to the to the reunions or
to the events I have senior leaders say
hey thank you for for handling yourself
the way you do in regards to all of that
and um and so even the question of what
team it's it's like anyone can talk
about it's not a big deal but for me
it's just like a personal line that I'm
really trying to stay with conviction of
of not diving too far and going into
publicly I don't you know I've had
people online say Dave Castro was never
the seal that Jocko Goggins or whoever
was after they said someone else and I
don't know another public seal and like
you're only saying that
because you know so and no like no
offense at all but because of how of the
seal things they show and talk about
yeah and like I don't want people to
know what kind of seal it was what level
seal I was and I I don't
um I don't want to be known as that guy
and I want to
um and forgive me for like I'm not
saying you're known as that guy it's all
good man but um and I also want to show
an example to
younger seals that hey you can kind of
transition out or get out and do
something and not lean on it so much
because I think you'll agree with me
here there's some guys that are way
um I don't say abusive with it but over
the top yeah I mean for me it's like
well this is what I did for 20 years of
my life there's no like well
hey here's 20 years of my life these are
the lessons that I learned this is where
everything came from
that's the way it is
um you know the the to to your point of
like well geez Dave Castro must not have
been as good of a seal as Jocko that's
just embarrassing yeah because both you
and I know that there's seals that did
25 deployments yeah and are the most
heroic guys ever I you know they're just
outstanding and they're no one knows who
they are no one knows who they are
outside the community and that's the way
they want it and that's the way they're
gonna be and the so so that's just like
a terrible thing to even think about
um there's this like pop iconic culture
now pop seals there's like these icon
seals who are and you're one of them and
and I and you know it's funny and it's
totally fine and I respect it and um
when at first have these conversations
with people about you or Goggins and I
would say hey I don't have a problem
with what they're doing it's just not
the way I want to do it and and in
regards to
even your situation you're exactly right
it's your experiences and I want to say
something I just since you decided to
ask me on the podcast I decided to pick
this up and I decided to start reading
it and I'm 100 pages in and it's
great you did a really good job with it
and um but for years any of these books
any of the other ones out there I
wouldn't touch or read or or even
acknowledge the movies I don't watch
um other than a rock other than the rock
oh it's legit oh and let's talk about
active Valor in a second I'm gonna write
that down
well I'll talk about it now active Valor
I think was a breaking point for a lot
of these seals out there and a huge
mistake of our leadership in sending the
wrong message to our community and
here's why I say that even before active
Valor especially after Vietnam and
marcinco era there'd been a lot of seals
who did books seals even before the
modern area more common than it felt
like some of the other special forces
Delta you name it
then I felt like active Valor was this
moment where we were all taken advantage
of meaning the Navy the command the
leadership said we're going to take
seals and we're going to put you guys in
a movie and we're going to utilize your
likeness to profit off of essentially to
recruit with and um and you're not going
to get anything from it and so you have
all these guys at that time saying well
the Navy did it with us why can't we do
it why can't we do it when we get out
why can't we capitalize on what we've
done and so I think Act of Valor laid
the foundation for opening up the
floodgates for sending the message to a
lot of guys
um hey it's good I'm gonna I'm gonna get
out there with it yeah I I don't know
much about the back story neither do I
and I'd be curious of what the back
story is I do know that here's what I
know about it they were initially gonna
make like some kind of a modern version
of the be someone special video yeah
which was a video that I watched in 1989
that showed this really cheesy example
of like what your job was in the SEAL
Teams yeah and from what I understand
they initially brought a company on
board to make a 20-minute you know hey
this is what the SEAL Teams is and that
company came on board and said hey
we don't you shouldn't just make a 20
minute video you should make an actual
feature film and we think we could do a
great job with it and for some reason
again I don't know the backstory
leadership said yeah that sounds like a
good idea I don't know why they did that
I don't know if we were having problems
recruiting
um I don't think we were having problems
recruiting but so I at some point I'll
dig and and see what I can find out and
see why the why that decision got made
because it certainly was a complete
departure from you know the way
the way that I was certainly raised in
the SEAL Teams when I was raised in the
SEAL Teams it was like you didn't talk
about it you definitely like you there
was no stickers there was no nothing
that's just the way it was and that was
you know for me
man when when I remember Leif and I who
wrote extreme ownership with me like the
I wish I would have recorded like the
first call we had with our publisher I
was such a jerk you know I was just like
listen if this was gonna misrepresent
this and all I I was just it was because
it was a huge like step right and it
felt uncomfortable you know I had one of
one of my friends who was an admiral was
like
he said something that I was very
appreciative of which was
hey where
quiet professionals that doesn't mean
silent professionals and if you have
important things that should be shared
then they should be shared and I was
like well okay now look there's you can
you can argue against that all day long
there's there's an easy to say yup
that's and you shouldn't share
anything and that's absolutely a valid
opinion uh but that's the that's the
direction that I went in like hey man
was I was working with these companies
and these people were falling over
themselves saying this is such good
information thank you so much
and then it's like well we could really
help out a lot of people if we do this
so there you go and it and that's
balanced against the fact that
when you write a book that's about you
about you know I wrote a you know Leif
and I wrote a 300 page book that's about
us and that's all that's that's all you
need to say okay so you're you're
tooting your own horn or whatever the
case may be yup yeah that's there's no
there's no denying it and so you do the
best you can I do I think we did the
best we could to maintain like
professionalism humility I mean the
things about you know
um as far as like classified material
and stuff that wasn't even
to me that's just a non-starter
obviously uh
and you know for us the combat that we
were in was in front of the world it was
in daytime it was like there was no
there was nothing secret about what
we're doing at all uh you know like we
had when we had guys get killed it was
in the newspaper the next day it wasn't
some big secret their names like it was
that's the way it was so we kind of felt
like we were a little bit exposed
anyways
um but yeah it'd be interesting to find
out and pull the thread on Act of Valor
and see what the what the thought
process was behind that because I don't
know even the way from what I've read I
think you guys are portraying in a great
way and everything you're saying about
like your experiences and what you're
you're helping the world and giving back
and and giving some great Leadership
Lessons and insight to at this point
millions of people right
um but there's other guys who are not
there's other guys who are just talking
and telling their story and just like
um some of these some of these cats will
say
I even look at
I look at what they're talking about and
I look at where they're at in life and
I'm like dude that was 15 years ago that
was 20 years ago that's another reason
why I'm like hey I've done but I you
know
um this is a podcast so of course we're
gonna talk about the past but I'm like
hey there's a lot I've done since then
and and I don't I kind of view it as
like I don't want to be a defined solely
by then I want to be to find what I've
done since then yeah well I definitely
have talked to a lot of people about the
fear of becoming Uncle Rico yeah right
and being like you know the state
championship if I would have thrown them
all to be good to go I would have won
the state I would have gotten recruited
like hey man these are these are I've
learned some awesome lessons we learned
some awesome lessons pass them on but I
mean my life since I I've been busier
yeah since I retired than I was when I
was in yeah but and you have a lot you
have a lot of you've built a lot and you
have a lot of stuff to talk about since
then I think some of these guys who are
talking and there's a lot of them are
they don't have that that new experience
even you know the other thing too though
in my my situation I also I was in a
very people even asked me for transition
advice sometimes other team guys and I'm
actually the worst person to give that
because my situation was super unique
the last three years I was an instructor
um before I got out 2000 my ninth year
to basically 12th year and I was working
full-time for CrossFit and so here I was
I was which is another reason you keep
that stuff on the down low because if
you got in all kinds of trouble yeah or
maybe you had permission I can't get
permission I had informal permission
let's say uh my leadership knew but it
wasn't formally written um
I was doing the CrossFit thing on the
weekends because I had a fixed schedule
and and working for CrossFit I'm sorry
in the Navy as an instructor so I had to
make a decision to stay in and if I
stayed in I'd go back and be operational
and wouldn't be able to do the CrossFit
thing or get out and work full-time for
CrossFit and and leave the Navy and it
was a tough decision to make because I
loved if I didn't have that CrossFit
opportunity I would have stayed in for
20 for sure I'd have been retiring
around this period
but so where I'm going with that is it's
easy for me to sit up here and talk all
bold and like yeah I I'm not
gonna tell people what I did and where I
was at because I had this nice
transition I had this huge buffer where
I was able to get out and not and I was
getting out with a public Persona and
building a new uh working with a new
company building it up
my transition was one of a it was super
seamless and and not too people don't
get that chance too often a lot of other
guys like yourself like you you got out
at 20 and then kind of had to start your
thing and chose the leadership route and
kind of had to build everything from
there and like you said capitalize on
and acknowledge what you did for the
last 20 years I can't say I would not
have done the same if I had to get out
and didn't have
um the didn't have CrossFit yeah and so
I do acknowledge that it was a unique
situation for me so I don't want to
sound like I'm
um acting better than anyone else it's
just it and I don't and honestly like
everyone again to the kind of the free
speech thing
um everyone's if they can pursue
whatever they want talk about it however
they want share even though some of that
stuff they shouldn't share share what
they've done it's all it's all good I
don't care too much at the end of the
day it's just not the style I'm choosing
yeah well and also there's just some
Market saturation at this point you know
what I mean like there's there's so many
incredible stories of things guys that
things are things that guys have done
from every branch of the service and
there's a lot of it I mean 20 years of
war you're going to get some incredible
stories you're gonna get some incredible
Lessons Learned and that that's I think
I think that's almost like uh it's
become a just a free market control is
that oh yeah you can get out and talk
about what you did in the green Braves
or what you talked with what you did in
the SEAL Teams or what you did in in
MARSOC or or whatever yep
but if there's not something compelling
there that's that brings something to
the table for people then the free
market will just kind of say hey thanks
you know appreciate thanks for your
service and and move on and I think
that's happened with a number of these
books a number of these stories there's
so many seal books out there not all of
them are hitting anymore like you have
to have you have to have a compelling
message you have to have something with
value that's going to make people really
gravitate towards it and consume it yeah
yeah no I'd say there's no doubt about
that uh and we went down this little
freaking tangent because I was like okay
so what team do you go to so you go to
an East Coast team how's your how's your
how do you like being a new guy
um that's a great question I yeah I mean
you don't right like being a new guy
isn't a pleasurable experience but
um even when I got to teams I was kind
of just staying in the middle try to
stay the um
be the Invisible Man but there it's you
quickly realize you have to you can't
you have to stand you have to because
it's such a smaller group
yeah exactly and you're in the you're on
the spotlight
um a majority of the time
um but
I was quiet and I was a really hard
worker and I wanted
um I wanted to prove myself even even
now but even then I felt like I had
something to prove even now I still feel
like I have something to prove and so
working hard mattered and um and showing
my leaders and not even my leaders but
the guy to the left and right of me that
I was a good contributor and ultimately
a good warrior meant a lot to me and so
I I worked really hard and tried to um
try to excel at everything I did even
though I wasn't winning everything I did
I tried to win everything I did well
people can tell when you're trying and
it's hard to win stuff when you're a new
guy now look you might win a run you
might want to swim because you're coming
out of buds you're in good shape but
it's it's tough to beat a guy in
shooting it's tough to beat a guy in in
anything tactical but they can tell when
you're when you're working hard so this
is still pre-911 right yeah and on that
note it's still pre-911 and I I have a
ton of respect for every seal anyone in
the military who enlisted after 9 11. I
did not you did not we we basically
enlisted in peace time and um
I I'd like to say I mean I think I would
I have I know I would have but it's
still it takes a little more knowing
that um after 9 11 if you enlisted and
came into these career Fields you were
probably going to war yeah and well I
did technically I thought I was going to
Nam when I listened
and and I remember one of my buddies who
also came to the teams so what year was
that
1990 was when a guy that I went to MEPS
with yeah and he ended up in the teams
ended up a master chief just a freaking
awesome guy if we were like riding the
MEPS bus down to the airport and we're
talking about you know he was a wrestler
and so we're talking about I was like
you know he I think he said to me like
are you are you trying for you trying
for Buds and I was like yeah are you
yeah
and of course there was you know a bunch
of guys that were trying for buds but
but uh anyways he had been to college
yep and I was kind of like dumb and but
he was telling me hey you know the
casualty rate of seals I think it was
him that told me this the casualty rate
of seals is like 50 the chance of
finishing a career at 20 years is like
it's almost nothing and I was like for
hell yeah like we're going to war I
think he must have read that and if
again if I'm putting this on this guy I
I'm sorry
but some I heard that rumor in boot camp
I'm pretty sure it was him that was like
hey it's really hard to retire as a seal
because chances are you're just gonna
get killed yeah and I remember being
fired up about that I was like hell yeah
and then of course I got to you know
Seal Team One in 1991 and missed the
first Gulf War and yeah realized pretty
quick I wasn't going to Vietnam but yes
these guys that were coming in
post 911
and especially once it was really
obvious that this was going to be a long
War like if you were enlisting in 2005
2006 2007.
yeah you know what you're getting into I
remember Tim Kennedy saying that
when he went to enlist on September 12th
like there's a line around the building
I remember I called the officer detailer
and on September 12th you know and I was
in the Navy had me in college at the
time and I was saying Hey sir you know
send me send me your team right now
please I'll graduate later and he he
says you know hey it's gonna be a long
War don't worry but I was actually
talking to him a couple years ago and he
said
I was like yeah I remember calling you
he said everybody called me and I was
like that's actually awesome you know
that's exactly how you want it everybody
in the teams wanted to go and fight did
you do semen Admiral or yes okay so I
did my first eight years at till team
one and then I got picked up for the
semen Admiral program I was in the
second class of semen Admiral program
and then went from Team One to OCS E5 a
team one OCS for 13 weeks and Senate
team two damn it was freaking awesome
yeah I didn't realize you're on the East
Coast yep yep I went to team two
um
but
that new guy experience that you had I
mean I
you know even though it's like oh
there's nothing uh nothing to like about
it but damn it's freaking awesome being
a new guy in a seal platoon well it's
super formative it's super like
foundational to where you go and what
you become and how you succeed or don't
succeed in the community and I think
back to some of the mentors and the guys
who really uh developed me at that point
they're tremendous in your life they are
super influential again in this notion
of where you end up and what you become
and what choices you decide to make so I
had some guys that I really respected
that helped develop me and bring me
along so were you like a point man I'm
guessing yeah yeah just like you'd guess
you're a 60 Gunner I was actually a
radio man okay yeah that was I signed up
to be a radio I heard an officer told me
on Quarterdeck watch he said if you
wanna if you want to go on every Mission
you should be a radio man and I was like
probably the only guy in the history of
Seal Team one that walked up to the
radio room the next day and knocked on
the door and said I want to be a radio
man like no one ever wanted to be a
reader except for that so it was great
advice though uh so you you end up a
point man
and then you're going on these are
peacetime deployments you're training
people you're doing exercises and all
this kind of thing
um September 11th comes how long did it
take for you to go from peacetime
deployments to wartime deployments much
longer than I thought it would I think
when it first went down we were all like
oh here we go it's real we're gonna
go to we're gonna go to war now
um at that period
the especially with the the teams I was
at that it wasn't every Seal Team didn't
push out and everyone even within a year
afterwards it was very clear to get into
combat that I had to make a few career
choices career decisions and and
basically put myself put myself out of
the line kinda to to do that that I had
to take a different step and so I did
that and then I went to a team where
okay it's real we're going to combat
right away and um then did a few
deployments did multiple appointments
and went through that uh phase on that
uh 911 I remember I was in Montana and
we're training the black feet uh we're
training on the black feet Blackfoot
reservation Indian reservation and we're
working with the Bia the Bureau of
Indian Affairs and we had gone to their
facility and I'll never forget this it's
so crazy a few days before 9 11. we're
looking at at the FBI top 10 list and I
was just skimming it and I saw Bin Laden
and it just stood out to me I'm like oh
look Osama Bin Laden and I knew of him
from the coal bombing and that incident
and was like that I remember him and
being on that FBI top 10 list standing
out and then a few mornings later we
were staying at a resort hotel I
remember walking into the lobby and
everyone huddled around the TVs and that
had just happened and seeing the planes
hit the towers and at that point you
know it was still I think pretty quickly
though within a week or two they tied it
to him maybe even within a few days they
tied to Bin Laden I don't remember do
you
I don't remember when it got tied in I
mean I remember
the second plane hitting and it was like
then it was real obvious yeah and I also
remember hearing because I was
not drawn to the TV and I was going I
was actually going to college at the
University of San Diego and I show up
there and I'm kind of listening to radio
and there's some little something you
know they're saying there's some news
break oh there's been a plane hit the
World Trade Center
I don't you know I figure a Cessna you
know what I mean like I just didn't they
didn't they didn't make it sound like
what it as big as it was and so I I'm
going to class I just turn off the radio
go to classic I thought it was just uh
Cessna hit the hit the tower get done
with class and I go to I actually go
train Jiu Jitsu and when I get to jiu
jitsu
there like no one at Jiu Jitsu watches
TV that's just like not happening and I
get to my Jiu Jitsu Academy and
everyone's watching TV and I'm like what
is going on and sure enough the second
tower had been hit and yeah next thing
you know I'm calling my detailer trying
to figure out how I can get back to a
single team well much later in the whole
in in the conflicts
um it the more all teams are getting
involved I think in that first
um like even
um that first call it three to
five six period 03 or I'm sorry oh one
two maybe four or five there was small
amounts of guys going out especially
once that racks
um popped up too then it's like all the
teams were getting a lot of action yeah
so
in 0-3 I went to Iraq and in 04.
my whole team showed up so I had one
platoon in Iraq in O3 yep and then you
know I was at Team seven and then and
then the whole team showed up yep and it
was like then that was it from then on
the teams rotating teams and that was
like in the beginning when it was just
Afghanistan that definitely wasn't the
case oh yeah definitely not yeah
definitely not because it was a rapid
deployment what uh period is this
um so most of the battle ramadi that we
talk about in that book is 2006. okay
2006 from April until October 2006. okay
and so I we were we were
um anyways over there with guys I don't
even know were you over there at that
time were you and I were around six I
was back I was not deployed yep
um
so you're we kind of already talked
about the fact that you were in
Afghanistan doing missions and you're
you're feeling good on the patrolling
you're feeling okay on the patrol out
but maybe on target you're feeling like
maybe a little bit of lightweight yeah
it's interesting so I'm doing a lot of
training right now with uh we're working
with General Donahue he's a three star
in charge of 18th Airborne Corps 18th
Airborne Corps is hundreds of thousands
it's massive and we he's tasked us with
uh he was in charge of 82nd Airborne
before this post 82nd Airborne he's um
tasks us to do CrossFit training with um
third infantry third ID in Fort Stewart
so we're conducting some training with
their soldiers out there and where I'm
tying this into or why I brought that up
is because
same thing with hair train
he said he's like training for an
athletic contest and even you reference
to and you hear a lot of the strength
and conditioning coaches talk about how
like
um our training should be more like
athletes and professional athletes in
general it's actually fascinating
because as I've thought about it it's
athletes and professional athletes
specifically the demands of their Sport
and their job are so clearly defined I
think we need to have a mental reset
where no we need to train like combat
Warriors and we need to be proud of that
and we need to be proud that it's
different than being a professional
athlete because what we're training for
you have no idea what you're up against
and and in this effort with the Army
hearing some of the other Fitness
Specialists or Fitness professionals and
other soldiers talk about training like
a professional athlete or training like
an athlete it's it's actually the wrong
perspective you should train like this
the Combat Warrior or soldier that you
are and be proud of that and that is a
very different demand and requires very
different skill sets than the clearly
defined I mean even you take a fighter
where they have great conditioning and
they're um
um great athletes they're pro athletes
some of them they're the what they have
to train for is in a box they understand
three minute rounds or five minute
rounds one minute rest
um and within that they have to be
incredibly capable obviously but they
don't need to train for five hours or
they don't need to train for 48 hours
out there
um
the demands of a soldier the demands of
a warrior are everything and anything
yep it could be everything from uh 13
kilometer Patrol one day rest for the
day another 10 kilometers the next night
you get on a Target somewhere then
you've got to kick open a door then
you've got to haul something then you
gotta grapple with someone yeah then you
gotta lift that person into a v like
there's there's such a unlimited
variation that you can come up against
that you really do have to
train and prepare for that even though
it's funny as I have one of my training
Partners a guy named Miha he's a you
know really good Jiu Jitsu black belt
and for we I've been training with him
for the last six months or so and we
have been training the entire time with
five minute rounds that's just a second
car standard you know you get to want to
roll with a bunch of different people so
we do the five minute rounds and all
good
and we went on a trip we went on we went
on a trip and all of a sudden it's just
me and him and we were doing no time
limit rounds just like we're training
two submission
and he mentioned it you know he got done
he's like it's a lot different
when we're going with no time limit and
I was like yeah I hadn't really thought
about it but I was like oh yeah there's
a lot of you know all of a sudden it's
not the explosiveness is down the
endurance is up like it's a different
strategy it's different tactics and it's
different even from a physical
conditioning perspective so then you
take that's just one element of combat
now you take that and multiply it times
the infinite different things that you
can face
and and you realize man you gotta you
gotta condition yourself like you said
it's not
it's not a sport yeah no a sport has
rules yep then there's got to be a
mentality change and shift in a lot of
leaderships and soldiers who kind of say
that because it's easy to default to
that and it's easy to think oh we need
these this guy who taught the Dallas
Cowboys or the strength conditioning
coach from there like yeah those guys
are well educated they've trained
professional athletes but that doesn't
translate necessarily to working with
Warriors and that's something very
special I want to ask you this about
striking because you you brought it up
in general or fighting I should say I'm
a big believer that if I were to start
someone from scratch now at this point
to prepare for
um physical combat I think striking is a
good start to keep people away and then
actually before Jiu Jitsu I think
learning Judo and the skills of Judo
trying to get people off and keep them
away with prior to going to the ground
actually creates a well-rounded capable
fighter what do you guys think about
that yeah I heard some quote recently
and I actually covered on the podcast I
can't remember exactly what it was but
it was something along the lines of
if I have two hours to prepare you yep
we're not even going to talk about
grappling yeah if I have two weeks to
prepare you I'm gonna start to address
it if I have two years to prepare you
that's where I'm going to start okay
because it does take a lot longer to
learn and
um you know I always recommend if you're
gonna commit to something and you're
gonna train you should start with Jiu
Jitsu the reason is because
if you're if we're in a striking
combat if we're in a fight and you boxed
and I didn't I can run away from you
yeah if you want to kick me and you're a
kickboxer I can run away from you
I don't have to actually fight you until
you grab a hold of me and then my
kicking doesn't work my punching doesn't
work what works is grappling or works as
Jiu Jitsu and if you wrestled and I
didn't wrestle you're gonna take me down
like to this day like I didn't wrestle
in high school yeah if somebody wrestled
in high school they're gonna take me
down yeah that's what's gonna happen
like you they spent four years yeah you
know three hours swimming thing yeah
it's kind of like the swimming thing so
they're gonna get the takedown so what I
have to get good at is I have to get
good at Jiu Jitsu I have to get good at
from a self-defense perspective getting
back up off the ground getting away from
them breaking contact
so that's what that that's how I would
answer that question uh Judo is great
Judo is great the throws in Judo are
great the they rely on the the takedowns
in wrestling
comprehensively
are more reliable but if it's pure
self-defense and you know a good Judo
throw man that's really good people
you're dealing with somebody that's got
clothes on you can grab a hold of their
clothes there's no grabbing clothes in
wrestling
that means also if I have to grab
clothes and the clothes aren't there my
my moves don't work if I'm arrested if
I'm a judo player so being well-rounded
it almost goes back to the same theory
of Fitness which is
being well-rounded and having an open
mind and being
decent at a lot of different things is
probably going to be better than being
an expert in one thing and that was
really proven out in the early ufcs
which is this guy that's a pure boxer
is losing to you know hoist Gracie this
guy that's a Pure Taekwondo is losing to
a wrestler
you'd see that these purists and then
the pure wrestler is losing to the Jiu
Jitsu guy the Jiu Jitsu guy was the most
rounded at the time yep and
if you take just pure one sport or one
technique
or one ART versus one other art Jiu
Jitsu clearly was the winner that's
that's been proven
so
that being said nowadays you have to
learn everything yeah and you want to
learn everything so you know when we
were dealing with combatives in the SEAL
Teams
one of the arguments that got I got told
about certain systems was hey you know
Jiu Jitsu takes too long to learn MMA
takes too long to learn we only can
train these guys for five days or seven
days or two weeks so we have to give
them something that's going to help them
immediately and I said hey how long have
you been in the teams for
nine years 12 years seven years I go hey
man you don't have two weeks to learn
how to fight and you can't learn how to
fight in two weeks you you have a career
to learn how to fight so learn how to
fight and then you'll be much much
better off
and to some degree combatives and the
fight in general
um there's obviously a lot of skill that
comes with it but
um there's a warrior mindset and like a
perspective that this guy in front of me
is not going to stop me and I'm gonna
go through him or do whatever it
takes and it might not Express in the
perfect technique in the perfect form
but there's an aggression that I saw
that I think sometimes even trumps a lot
of traditional training you think of
some of the guys that we worked
with guys bigger than you guys as big as
you that weren't as well trained as you
and combat is still beasts and still
able to muster up the fight and the
aggression to take anyone out yeah no
there's there's a level of
just being aggressive that is going to
be very very helpful in a combat
situation
especially with a lot of the people we
would come across meaning probably not
trained exactly like it's
you come up against a 160 pound you know
43 year old Iraqi dude like you're 227
pound freaking seal that can bench 380
like and his and he's hostile dude he's
gonna bring it that dude that that Iraqi
doesn't he's not going to cause much of
a problem now that being said I saw with
my own eyes guys getting guys having
problems controlling yeah Iraqis
I saw that with my own eyes I mean one
of the very first like times I was out
in Iraq 2003 and we were doing a vehicle
interdiction and we
we get this vehicle pulled over
and I'm the Ground Force Commander so
I'm kind of like you know got my gun at
high Port I'm kind of observing the
whole situation making sure everything's
cool and all of a sudden I hear this guy
calling for help like a seal and I'm
like this is weird so I walk over and
sure enough he's in a he's in
hand-to-hand combat
with like a 15 year old kid and he's not
winning yeah and so I go over and it
takes me two seconds to get the guy
under control and get get it solved but
he was panicked the 15 year old kid was
panicked he doesn't know what the hell's
going on so he's freaking out he's do
you get that pain like we used to hear
pain compliance
pain compliance also causes pain
non-compliance because if you start
torquing on my wrist or torquing on my
shoulder I get I react to it and my
reaction might seem like hostility to
you so that you apply more pressure that
makes me fight even harder next you know
we've escalated the situation
the one of the good things about
training combatives all the time Jujitsu
boxing Muay Thai wrestling all that
stuff is that you are very used to
physical confrontation
it happens to me every single day like
an hour before you got here I had a
bunch of savage dudes trying to choke me
right grabbing my neck grabbing my arm
trying to knock me down to the ground
but that's what I do every day and when
you get used to that
it just becomes very very natural much
like you already pointing out the
example of someone that swims like this
dude no fins yeah and that guy passed
poo comp easily and he's not freaking
out you take some kid from Iowa that
didn't spend much time in the water they
get in the water they freak out yep so
doing this stuff regularly
is extremely important you know that
that's another thing with like
parachuting right
I would use the comparison like who does
better well if you're getting if you if
you get into sport parachuting right
you get really good at sport parachuting
and then guess what when you put on a
rock and a weapon it's not like oh now
you're all confused because you got a
rock and a weapon on no those people
that are sky Gods yeah and have 6 000
civilian jumps they have six thousand
civilian jumps you can put anything on
them and they know how to handle it they
make it happen it's not like they go no
uh same thing with well same thing with
sport shooting and you know what so I've
since I got out of the teams I became an
avid shooter and I shoot in a lot of
different disciplines and that's that's
my passion now so I spend a lot of my
off time
um competing in Shooting Sports and in
the teams when I was at least when I was
coming up and especially on the East
Coast there was no culture for for uh
pursuing the Shooting Sports outside of
um of being a team Guy and um and the
training that we did the army guys some
of the army guys I saw they actually had
a pretty good culture of competing
outside of um of work in some of these
civilian competitions and to this day
they still do I've actually recently
worked with guys from one and a few
other teams down here in trying to help
them expose them more to the civilian
competition world because if you're
shooting civilian competitions you are
way better than everyone else who's
shooting just in the teams and I think
that our operators aren't fighting
enough like you said they're not making
that a premium and they're not shooting
enough and those two things pursuing it
but it's also like it's so easy to say
from the outside but it's also like hey
our time is so precious and asking
someone to shoot on the weekend you know
that's they're taken away from an
already real or taking their time away
from their family with an already really
busy schedule but um because when I
first got out I I mean I accomplished a
lot in the military I've worked with
some of the best units I was a good
shooter and then I went and shot some
civilian competitions and I failed I
mean I finished like at the very bottom
and I saw how slow I was so my eyes were
opened and I'm a huge believer it's just
like the sport parachuting aspect like
you pursue that stuff a little bit on
the side and you're gonna make yourself
a much better Warrior and prepare for
combat yeah like you were a lead climber
yeah exactly so you're a lead climber
when you're out climbing uh El Cap are
you wearing all your gear for combat no
but when you're now in combat and you
got your gear on and you have to figure
out some kind of a problem you're going
to be infinitely better and some people
used to say we're gonna get bad habits
do you remember that that was one of the
things you're gonna get bad habits
you're gonna get bad habits and I was
like man if you're that good at civilian
shooting those bad habits that you have
are just going to be nothing they're
going to be they're they're they're
gonna be good I think we um and I
actually it's interesting I think you've
learned skills to apply to different
scenarios meaning what we can be called
a bad habit while in the sport let's say
you're um
you're drawing from the side and you're
engaging and then you're holstering
without sweeping right and that would be
considered a bad habit when you get to
the environment or the training
environment with the SEAL Teams where
you have to us look left and right
you'll know to do that yeah like you're
smart enough and trained enough to adapt
to different situations with different
skill sets from the same realm yeah
meaning there's a lot of different
techniques it's like it's like um well
to go back to the climbing stuff too
for ascending a rope there's uh people
would say okay so you use this prusik
knot and then you tie here and you
create this system and you ascend a line
and I would I would I learned early on
don't learn the not learn the system
learn okay you need a friction knot here
not necessarily A prusik there's
probably five different friction knots
you can apply to this scenario so even
to these days and the same probably same
of Jiu Jitsu there's a lot of different
ways to tackle a single problem uh
obviously in the beginning it might make
sense to teach one but then you have to
educate conceptually I need to build a
toolbox so in in leadership too same
sort of principle and so this is sort of
the attitude that opened your mind to
CrossFit absolutely and for me again I
was watching an old clip
that we recorded on this podcast a long
time about about CrossFit somebody asked
me like what do you think of CrossFit
and I actually compared oddly enough I
actually compared CrossFit with the
Gracie family because
if the Gracie family didn't exist
we would not have the UFC we would not
have mixed martial arts we would not
have this incredible progress and
open-mindedness that has now become
the core belief inside of mixed martial
arts anyone that's a mixed martial
artist right now which pretty much if
you train martial arts now you're a
mixed martial artist
your premise is there's going to be new
things that work there's going to be
some things that don't work if something
works it's good if it doesn't work it's
bad if it doesn't work we don't throw it
away but we definitely are going to
consider what the benefits are and when
is the appropriate time for it but the
key component being my mind is open to
to what is happening
I looked at you know CrossFit now I was
a an odd person that had always kind of
been into
strongman Olympic lifting now I never
had an Olympic lifting coach I wish I
would have they didn't exist yeah when I
you know there's a magazine called Milo
I've been a I was a subscriber For Milo
from like 1994 I think is when I have my
first copies I still have them
and in there they had Olympic lifting
they had strong men they had power
lifting
they had those things in there and so I
knew about them but I like me doing a
cleaning jerk
you know was an embarrassment to the to
the world of technique but I knew about
it I knew about it
no one there wasn't a there wasn't a
place to learn clean and jerk in San
Diego there wasn't an olymp there wasn't
bumper plates in San Diego there wasn't
bumper plates at the SEAL Teams nope
so
CrossFit came in
and actually I remember is the reason I
asked you the date when you were
researching it you were researching
about it so I was on deployment in 2003.
and remember I said my my the whole team
showed up including my commanding
officer and I pretty sure he's the guy
that said to me hey if you heard of this
stuff
and I was like No And I started looking
at it and I said to him hey newsflash if
you pick up heavy stuff yeah and you do
it over and over again you're gonna get
stronger and you're gonna get in better
shape I acted like this was common sense
and it was a little bit of common sense
to me but I don't give myself too much
credit I'm not trying to say I'm
definitely not trying to say I I had
that but like like
but let me say if one piece you're not
saying but you understood and uh
inherently and and what's one of the
reasons why cross is so effective is the
intensity aspect of it 100 and picking
up heavy under intensity and
intensity and Crossfit translates to the
things being timed sorry to interrupt
but I just wanted to say this
interestingly enough nowadays especially
with even some spec operators or some
pro athletes intensity is incredibly
vulnerable intensity you see it in
fighting I mean you you're you have to
be um
if you don't have intensity you're gonna
get choked out but in in training people
are now doing the movements but taking
the intensity out because they don't
want to be exposed they don't want to be
seen training under duress or a snot
coming out screaming making you know
shaking and no you can't scream anymore
that's when you're really there is when
there's no more noise to be made you got
nothing left so so the intensity piece
too is what you were talking about in
the very beginning yep yeah and that so
so CrossFit comes in so when did you
when did you so it was 2003 2004 that's
when you actually started doing it so uh
probably four five I was doing it and
then in
um
six or seven six I was in Monterey and I
started working out with or I knew
CrossFit was based out of
um Santa Cruz and so I started going
over there met Glassman started
introduced myself to him and just
started uh training with them and that's
are you going to school in Monterey oh
okay yep and so that's how I um that's
how I was connected to Glassman he had
always been super welcoming of um
military guys especially at that time
and so he found out I was in the Navy
let me train there for free started
inviting me to events started uh was
this the actual Santa Cruz Jazz yep that
actual original gym started um offered
me a spot at a level one seminar I went
to the level one seminar with a few
other seals then he asked for me to
attend some and help out and so I
started going to them and helping out as
an instructor and what's interesting at
this point so this is six seven there
were a handful of other team guys that
were from West Coast that were in that
same Glassman Circle kind of
um working with him and part of his
little crew I'll say and and this is
0.607 yeah and so oh six for sure and I
um so my ass I'm pretty sure my
assistant platoon Commander who's with
me when my CEO said like hey what do you
think of this stuff and I was like Hey
lift stuff go hard you're gonna get in
better shape like he was my workout
buddy we were doing all kinds of stuff
like he he was doing the 20 rep squats
with me like like he's just a freaking
you know a badass athlete and we we were
we were getting after it and then when
we got back
he
he I think he went to buds as an
instructor and so that's why he had time
to go and start to get engaged with
Crossfit well we ended up having lunch
uh maybe in eight or nine with Glassman
and Nicole Carroll okay so we had lunch
at um Coronado Brewing Company okay and
I think that's the first time I met you
and I'd known of you I was still an
instructor at that point and uh yeah the
four of us sat down I remember that
lunch for some reason I don't remember
what we talked about but we hung out
yeah yep
um and that's why so I was going to ask
you this so I went to
a level one certification for the teams
I think it might have been the first one
that you guys put on it was preemie for
sure okay so I was Greg they were doing
seminars before I was coming around got
it yeah so they were doing those uh
level ones before I was coming around
and then I got involved and what's
interesting in that the the
life lesson and the the thing I talked
to people about from my experience in my
engagement with Crossfit at that stage
I accomplished a lot in the military I
had you know done a full spectrum of
things I was at the top of the tip of
the spear call it for who we were and um
here I was kind of introduced to a new
community introduced to a new
um almost opportunity job opportunity
and
there was a couple different paths to go
one was sitting there and being like
well I'm a seal I've done this I'm I'm
good just like ramp me up to the front
of the line and or just buckling
down and getting to work and I I took
this perspective of everything I
everything and I tell guys this now
everything you did in the past is
significant and it's foundational and
it's it's it's um
it's very it's why you are who you are
and it's taking you to multiple levels
but once and it'll open a lot of doors
for you but once those doors are opened
you have got to start over you've got to
prove value and show who you are here
and now and stop leaning on the past
stop living in the past and so that's
kind of was my
my way of operating when I first got
involved in CrossFit I was
taking the trash out and I was setting
up chairs and here I was I've been in
the Navy for nine ten years at that
point and again uh accomplished an
immense amount of things where I could
be proud of everything and not uh not
take trash out ever again or not set up
chairs but I started from the bottom and
just went in with like okay I'm the new
guy I'm a new guy again and that
attitude was really for me in getting
through and I'd call it advancing and
getting more opportunities with Crossfit
was
um significant and it was very powerful
and and it's something that I like to
tell guys hey man don't just be super
humble regardless of what you've done in
the past
two things number one my first uh
seminar
I need I feel like I kind of knew what
was up a little bit I was heads up so
kind of was talking to me like hey no I
remember
had the old school
um uh PVC homemade yeah rings and he
goes he's like oh you got to try a
muscle up and I was like what is it he
goes out like this and I and I remember
thinking to myself I gotta do this right
like it's just me and him me and him are
hanging out and the first try got it
a totally bad technique but what I
realized was like oh there's there's
things going on here so I remember I was
at that that level one was it in Ramona
no this is at the team okay okay they
did one for you there yep yep yep so
what year I don't know okay it's around
this time frame it's a round win I might
have been involved with that one yeah
you it might have been I it seems like
maybe that's why we were at lunch yeah
because yeah that might have been
because we did a few seminars at the
teams there yeah
um by the time I was coming around yep
so
I remember thinking this is a trick not
not in a bad way but I remember at the
first UFC was 1993 I already knew Jiu
Jitsu I I knew hoyce Grace he was going
to win that thing
they start saying like hey who wants to
do you know whatever who wants to who
thinks they can lift 95 pounds it's like
I see a couple Team guys raising here
and I'm like this is a setup dude you're
getting set up who wants to go against
the cold with this and I'm like dude you
guys are getting set up you guys are you
guys are getting smoke you're gonna get
crushed right now so I kind of knew what
was up I knew to keep my freaking Mouse
shut
up uh because if you don't train in
those modalities you're gonna be you're
gonna get caught totally off guard well
and a lot of the movements um especially
the ones they put guys up against Nicole
specifically the overhead squat the
flexibility just demand they're not
there for for a lot of guys unless
you've been training like this unless
you're Olympic weightlifting and or
crossfitting your shoulder Mobility
probably isn't there to have the bar in
a optimal position to do High Reps to do
with 27 reps exactly and while you're
face to face with Nicole yeah right
which is what which is what you're
getting yourself into yeah and this was
it got honestly it was like uh it was
like the first UFC because
people just didn't know people just
didn't know and they were like oh I got
duck and squat 380. what this girl's
gonna beat me no way give me that 95
pounds are you kidding me yeah and I was
like dude this is so you're about to get
choked out choked out physically uh in
the in the Physical Realm but but what
what an eye-opener right yeah what an
eye-opener to say oh there's a little
bit of a dip there's more to this than
just how much can you squat you know
what's your shoulder Mobility what's
your hip mobility what's your ankle
Mobility where are you at and do you
have it and by the way if you can't do
that what else can't you do where else
are you falling short and muscle up is
another great example like isn't it a
very important skill to be able to take
yourself your body weight and pull
yourself up
not just up to the bar but above the bar
yeah that seems like it doesn't take a
genius to go that seems like it might be
a really good skill to have I should be
able to do that and there's some
technique to it and there's some
strength to it and there's some
flexibility to it and I don't have those
things and I better figure them out
right now because I tell you what I did
that one well the first time I ever did
a muscle up I did one thank God I didn't
get asked to do another one because who
knows what would have happened so
that's what I saw
so as you go up to Santa Cruz and you're
just getting annihilated in workouts you
know and you're just thinking what is
going on how well they got me actually
with Nicole early on one of my first
sessions ever yeah they got me they got
me one of my first sessions ever at um
the CrossFit Santa Cruz I went to an
evening class and they get us in a big
circle and they're warming us up and
they warmed us up for um the push jerk
and I didn't have I had been doing
CrossFit now for probably eight or nine
months but I didn't never coached and so
didn't still doing a lot of these
movements poorly and um they're like all
right now we're gonna break up into
groups and we're gonna do this for I
think it was a one rep max load and so
they had four platforms out in the gym
it's a small gym and they go okay this
this platform's gonna have um the ladies
they're gonna gravitate towards that
group this platforms and have the
stronger ladies of the class this
platform's gonna have the men this
platform's gonna have the stronger men
and I go okay cool I started walking
over the stronger men platform
and uh the guy goes no no you're gonna
go to this fifth platform that was no
one was at yet and I was like oh don't
you think I should live with the dudes
and they're like no no go to this
platform and then I see and then I see
this 130 pound-year-old female putting a
bar on there and she's like tiny and um
I go hey man I don't know about this I
shouldn't be lifting with a female I
should be lifting with the guys and the
trainers like no no lift with her I'm
like all right maybe they just want you
know her to have someone to show her how
it's done and so we start barbell warm
up a couple reps the 25s go on do some
at 95 then the 35 45 is going on we're
on 135 I look around and like all of the
other groups the men one group of men
are at 145 the other is not the women
are not even close to that and we're
knocking out one uh some reps at 135 and
then she's adding more weight and more
weight and her form is impeccable the
entire time we get to 165 175 and again
that's not a lot but I wasn't I'm not a
big guy and at that time I was new to
these movements I hit whatever 175 and
I'm like oh that was stuff and then she
hits it no problem I was like this was a
setup and then uh we go to 185
and I miss it and she gets under it and
Nails it and we didn't talk to each
other a single moment was this Nicole
yeah this was the same the one they said
it shut down yeah and uh she crushed me
and uh I left that gym calling guys back
on the East Coast saying I
should turn in my Trident I just got
destroyed by by a female on a barbell
movement but that that's CrossFit and
just like Jiu Jitsu just like Jiu Jitsu
there's people that get choked out by
the 150 pound girl and they never come
back
and their ego is so destroyed that they
think oh this is a if this was a real
fight I would have done this and you
think you know well if this was a real
situation I'd just pick her up and throw
her to the ground
instead of going damn I got some
weaknesses I need to work on and that's
the difference it's very it's a humbling
experience just like Jiu Jitsu is a
humbling experience CrossFit is a very
humbling experience and you'll see
people doing movements that they've that
they've trained in yeah that's why it's
also similar Jiu Jitsu is like oh the
reason the 150 pound woman choked you
out isn't because she's a better human
being than you
it's because she's trained for that the
reason that Nicole beats you in clean
and press or whatever it was movement
you were doing isn't because she's a
better human being than you it's because
she's trained in it well you know to
that same note I would hear guys talking
about the shooting stuff again be like
like we'd hire external experts shooting
experts to um to work with us like oh
those guys shoot all the time that's why
they're good
exactly but like yeah like that's not an
insult like but people would say it as
an insult like he shoots all the time so
he's really good well yes you you guys
roll all the time so you're really good
that's part of being really good I I
tapped the guy out one time who is a
team guy and I was bigger than him and
stronger than him and I tap him out and
he goes you never would have got that if
you weren't so strong and I said that's
why I lift
I also want to say this like uh you said
it a while ago you were talking about
the fact that we don't shoot enough they
shoot a lot more now in the teams
they're they're doing way better and
they and they do more combatives way
more good across the board they're just
going to be better they're getting
better seals than we were because
they're just they got it they got it on
tap the shooting and the fitness
um less so with the combatives but you
might you might argue with this or you
might have an answer that I'm not
thinking of but it needs to be measured
and what I mean by the standards like
shooting there needs to be times and
everything if you're unless and same
with Fitness unless you're putting it
out there and competing and actually
okay what's your draw from a holster
with retention if you guys are just
going through the motions and not
actually measuring it and pushing it and
trying to get faster it's still great
right don't get me wrong but that's the
thing that takes it to the next level
same thing with Crossfit the fittest
guys and the fittest people are doing it
under a stopwatch and actually there's a
ceiling for intensity that we're all
capable of and they're actually training
there and pushing it and hitting on that
ceiling and you keep hitting it and you
raise it if you don't train with
intensity and hit that ceiling at all
you're never going to raise that ceiling
so the question then from that is back
to the combatives part how do you
measure and how do you um
you do what the US Army does okay you
have a massive combatives tournament you
have combatives tournaments on basis you
have people trained and you can make it
like hey you will compete in this and
that way you know who's training who's
not training and I think that's a great
way that they do that to get people to
train because if you're training you're
gonna know yeah if you're not training
yeah you're gonna get crushed so it's
very cool the way the army sets that up
I don't know if the Marine Corps has
those I don't know why I'm looking at
you Echo but I don't know if the Marine
Corps has uh has those combative
tournaments the way the Army does the
Army has legit oh the racer has the
Marine Corps what's it called and you
advance through that system so you get
like belts in their system what do you
think of that
I'm happy that people are training I'm
Overjoyed that people are training if
you take a marine that knows mcmap
compared to a marine that doesn't that
Marine that knows mcmap is going to win
10 10 9 times out of ten if not 99 times
out of 100. so I'm glad that they're
training uh you know and look belts to
me and that kind of stuff
never really I've never really been that
super into them uh I know why little
kids why it's called little kids like
belts you know little kids want to get
stripes on their belts and they want to
get that next color belt I get it
and and adults too you know some adults
that that they get some some goal
accomplishment right which is fine so I
think if it helps people train good but
that's easy coming from the super black
belt over here easy for him to say at
this point yeah I can say I never even
when I was in a black belt how long did
it take you to get to Black Belt ten
years damn yeah hey I respect the
out of Jiu Jitsu and their path towards
excellence and how they give them away
they give belts or not give away how you
earn a belt because it takes a
tremendous amount of effort and
commitment and and I especially in the
traditional martial arts that's not
there I mean you get people getting
belts in Taekwondo in a few years when
there's nine yeah exactly which is which
is unfortunate
um at this point so when did you
actually
leave the Navy what year was that
um 09 and so I had um
been working for CrossFit for about
three years at that point and an
instructor at Buds and that's where I
had to make were you a buds instructor
or sqt instructor okay yeah but it was
under blood today and that's why I say
that
um I had to make a decision and stay in
again if I was going to stay in I was
going to end up going back to being
operational and I wouldn't have been
able to do the work I was doing for
CrossFit or get out and work full time
for CrossFit and you got to understand
at that point in 09 CrossFit was already
like
blowing up like the games had been
around for three years uh our number of
seminars were exploding the number of
Affiliates were exploding I was already
becoming like a figure in the community
and so and honestly
financially I was able to take care of
my family much better if I pursued the
CrossFit route and didn't do the Navy
thing so it was a tough decision and and
I will say this about the time being
saying I don't talk a lot about stuff I
will acknowledge this story
shortly before getting out
I called one of my old team leaders from
the east coast and I said hey are you
guys pumping out anytime soon and he
said yeah we are I'm like I want to come
with you and so I asked leadership I'm
like hey can I go on a on a little
deployment they said yep and so
I hadn't signaled to the Navy or anyone
at this point that I was getting out but
a few months before I got out I was
fortunate enough to push over with my
with my old group and do a last
appointment to Afghanistan
that was pretty cool and it was
unique because well and this is a unique
piece that really nobody knows I was
overseas planning the CrossFit Games and
um planning seminars for CrossFit from
Afghanistan from internet we had
hijacked from some local Brits and uh
and so
um then I came and it was honestly again
I couldn't signal or tell anyone I was
doing that because they probably would
have not let me they wouldn't have let
me do that but I came back and was like
okay now I'm done like I I have it out
of myself got it out of your system yeah
and I needed that one last touch point
to know I could walk away from it now
um 10 years later no 14 years later
I made the right decision but sometimes
I'm like man I wish I would have stayed
in like and especially as the year if I
have as the years have passed I really
like appreciated what I did and who I
worked with and wish I would have um
done it longer but it the the outcome
would have never that was the right
choice at the right time I actually say
Glassman saved my life because I do
think especially you know the deal doing
the stuff we do and the number of times
you go overseas it's it's it's
ultimately becomes a numbers game and so
by giving me the opportunity to get out
and do this
um I feel like I do say that honestly
like he saved my life
but I loved it and I miss it and again
as time has gone on I really wish I
would have stayed in longer when I got I
got fired a year and a half ago two
years ago whenever it was when I got
fired the first thing I did is I texted
one of my buddies on the east coast and
said hey you guys need a shooter
and uh he thought I was joking I was
actually kind of serious but
um uh yeah so timing wise I was looking
at the the history
um 2002 in the year 2000 CrossFit was
was incorporated in 2001 the first gym
opened
in 2005 there was 13 CrossFit Gyms yeah
nuts Victory which is my gym we started
our CrossFit affiliate in 2007. I want
to find out what number we are oh we can
find that out for sure yeah I mean
that's pretty good to go and then there
was hot probably top two or three
hundred for sure it might have been yeah
um and again this is like for probably
right after we're doing these things
yeah it was late 2007 because we opened
our doors open here
January 2nd 2008. but we had everything
maybe in 2007 yeah uh
by 2013 there's 8 000 gems there's over
10 000 gems right now
so so in 2009 this thing is blowing up
yeah crossfit's totally blowing up
um you decide to get out and you're you
what was your job well at that point I
was running the seminar Department the
training department actually with Nicole
Carroll and I was running the CrossFit
games so I had created the CrossFit
Games the first three games seven eight
and nine were on the family ranch that I
grew up on uh the CrossFit Ranch and
they um after that we ended up 2010 we
had to move them out because the county
kicked us out but so I was in charge of
the games and um in charge of the
seminar Department two of the there was
three large sectors or departments at
the time of CrossFit it was training
um Affiliates and then the games and so
two of the three I was in charge of
which was and again that's a super
unique opportunity and and especially
well both of them it's kind of like I
just
um a lot of the hard work I put in and a
lot I the foundation to do that I laid
the foundation worked hard and kind of
I don't want to say
um
well again I think I mentioned this
earlier being a seal though I
acknowledge and respect opened the door
and opened the opportunity to be close
to the leadership crew there and then
once that happened I had to capitalize
on it and essentially did yeah you know
that's something that I when we were
talking about this earlier the the being
a seal people people respect that yeah
and they say oh you were a seal that
means you're a hard worker that means
you're disciplined that means you've
been in pressure situations I would more
I'm let come come work for me yep so
that door was open now
all those things that I just said about
being a seal I have various varying
degrees of being true right you might
not necessarily be a hard worker you
might not necessarily be disciplined you
might be a terrible leader there's
terrible leaders in the SEAL Teams
there's people that have terrible
judgment and they were seals so the door
there's a lot of doors that absolutely
get opened up but once you get inside
you you're gonna have to prove yourself
and that goes back to what you said
earlier just being humble and working
hard and keeping an open mind is going
to be the way to be successful if you
think you can ride being a seal
the the the the the what is it on the
movie Elf called the Santa Claus meter
you're not not tracking me over here no
the spirit meter the spirit meter for
being a seal only lasts so long then it
burns out and people like hey you
actually have a job that you're gonna be
able to do this and if you can't yeah
you're not gonna go very far you
obviously proved yourself you're working
hard you end up running these two big
portions of it and Crossfit starts to go
Richter now
with popularity comes
heat-seeking missiles from all
directions and
um so CrossFit
was the target of a lot of criticism
um like early on and right away and
what's crazy about that people ask me
like how I deal with some of the stuff
now at this point some of the public
stuff and I'm like man
I've been dealing with this for over 15
years and like early eight nine time
frame like you're already seeing
personal lift I'm already seeing
personal attacks I'm already seeing
people
um online trashing and destroying
CrossFit trashing and destroying me and
then as it just got larger that just
scaled up so it just scaled you know I I
find that a lot of times when people are
being critical of things my general
attitude is to say Well they're probably
right about something here like if
somebody says that I like uh am doing
something that doesn't seem to make
sense my initial reaction isn't no
they're wrong minus reaction okay well
what am I doing that's not making sense
and it seems like that attitude is a
good attitude to have as opposed to
getting super defensive and saying no
I'm actually perfect and why are you
questioning everything that I do do
people come at you at all I
they're all afraid of you
uh it's an odd thing um no no I I think
it's because
um
I would say I'm more I think because I
am open-minded about things
that I'm not probably not the funnest
Target to attack you know if you say I'm
not a great seal I'd be like yeah I
definitely wish I was a better seal if
you say I'm not that good at Jiu Jitsu I
would say yeah I definitely am not that
good at Jiu Jitsu if you say I'm not
that strong I would say I'm certainly
not that strong if you say I'm not that
smart I'd say you're right I wish I was
smarter so it's probably not that fun to
come at me because I don't you're
probably right if you're finding fault
with me I'm gonna say you're you're in
fact you are right
so when people have negative things to
say about me they're probably they are
correct and I nod my head and think
about how I can get better
and I think that you know is a is a
positive thing to do and it helps
to not feel
um you know like you're being ripped
apart when I just feel like I'm getting
good constructive criticism from the
world sometimes which is okay uh and I
think you know some of the criticisms
acrossfit along the way I've been like
yeah if you parse that out
I agree so if someone's like hey you can
get hurt if you don't learn to do
Olympic lifts well and then you do them
while you're very fatigued you can get
hurt absolutely that's correct you know
if you learn to do them correctly and
you you know a huge part of this is just
like Jiu Jitsu if you're if your ego is
driving you look if your ego's driving
you okay cool your ego should should
make you not want to tap out in Jiu
Jitsu your ego should want to get two
more reps your ego should want to you
know beat the time
but just like in in the SEAL Teams your
ego should say hey I want our platoon to
be the best I want to win this shooting
drill
but if your ego starts driving you to a
point where you're making bad decisions
now it becomes a problem just like in
your ego you you know you get your arm
broken
or your shoulder torn apart because you
didn't tap in Jiu Jitsu that's not
beneficial if your ego won't say you
know what my form is falling apart right
now and I need to scale this weight
you're gonna get hurt if your ego is you
know saying oh you know I'm competing
against Dave on the pistol right now and
I can see that his he could do this he
could make this movement a little
smoother on his on his holster but I'm
not going to tell him
so now I'm hurting my team so I can win
like those are terrible things so I I
think as I see and as I saw because I
again I mean we've had a CrossFit
affiliate here since
2007. as I saw those criticisms I'd say
yes that's correct here's what we need
to do to watch out for that oh the whole
idea again this is one of the things
just like Gracie Jiu Jitsu brought a lot
of things to
martial arts
the ideal of scalable workouts
I never heard of that never we didn't we
didn't hear about that in the SEAL Teams
I never heard about look hey if you're
gonna deadlift and you couldn't deadlift
as much as me sure you're gonna deadlift
less weight but it wasn't a thing yeah
it wasn't a thing so to say oh yeah if
you think you're gonna go and you're
gonna clean and jerk 135 30 times for
time and and that's 70 of your max clean
and jerk you're not being smart yeah and
you need to put your ego in check most
new people should not do 30 clean
injects at 135 for time but could they
do 30 cleaning Jerks with an empty PVC
pipe picking up a stick bringing it to
the shoulder and going overhead probably
and completely safely yep and so the
definitely the scaling aspect and what
people forget about a lot in the
criticism of the the danger of CrossFit
our core Charter we talk about in our
course is mechanics consistency and then
intensity and with mechanics it's about
learning how to do the movement learn
how to do it correctly and that Journey
probably isn't a 15-minute session at
your first session that Journey can be a
couple months mechanic consistent do it
well do it well over and over and then
after your mechanics are consistently
well good then you can add intensity and
then you go for time but that's been our
Charter from Greg wrote that scripted
that early on and that's what we teach
often ignored and often ignored in the
expression of it what I mean by that is
like sometimes trainers get people and
it's easy just to like go and like here
but we've got to really
it's so effective because it's so
complex and what I mean by that these
movements these complex movements
there's a lot of bang for your buck and
there's a lot of respect that needs to
come with that and they need to you need
to give them the intention that they
deserve with training and education on
how to do them prior to adding the
intensity piece because uh yeah
intensity and poor technique intensity
being going fast and High Reps for
example or a recipe for disaster on the
30 cleaning jerks at 135 the opposite
end of the spectrum now there's guys
that'll do 30 clean and jerks at 225.
you know so salute unheard of like
you're seeing the progression and the
the whole full spectrum of it yeah
um the uh and you know we the same thing
there was a lot of
criticism around like rhabdo yep and you
you can get rhabdo
um I don't know if I've ever had I don't
actually think I've ever had it
um I have not either I
I
think you know again the pro probably
in my opinion one of the primary causes
of rhabdo would be ego because if I'm
trying to hang with you and I haven't
worked out for the last four months or
six months or maybe two years and you're
doing a uh you're doing a heavy Fran and
I'm like I can actually do it
you know because I still have some
muscle memory and so now I push myself
so hard I'm not conditioned for it and
that's when we end up with issues again
ego and look as as instructor Cadre you
got to watch out for that stuff for all
these things you know the instructor
Cadre is responsible for saying
putting egos in Check Yes you know from
saying hey you know we have to do this
in Jiu Jitsu I remember this is with
kids training kids
I would be very I would always keep
close monitor on kids because kids don't
want to tap like their egos go crazy and
another kid's just like oh they're not
tapping cool I'm gonna keep going and so
I would stop for them and it's like you
have to have that mentality with adults
too
how when kids training kids how old
would the kids are the kids that are
training the kids no no they're training
again
I didn't realize yeah I see what you're
saying yeah they're just they're just
having matches they're not they're not
instructors
uh so it seems like if you
if you want to focus on the criticisms
and if someone's hearing about CrossFit
and they want to Google like what's bad
about CrossFit cool you can find what's
bad about CrossFit and if you don't say
what are the mitigating
approaches that handle these issues
then you won't know about them so I I
think it's a the education of what's
happening right now is getting people
educated where they're like okay I
understand what's going on understand
what the limitations are understand what
what guard rails need to be put in place
to mitigate these things from happening
we need to do we need to do a much
better job CrossFit does at this point
of educating Society on the safety and
efficacy of the program in general and
we need to all the safety protocols and
all the the path through even to this
intensity should be common knowledge to
anyone interested in this style of
training that like yeah CrossFit
mechanics consistency intensity CrossFit
they don't recommend that you go 100
when you first walk in there they
recommend you check your ego for the
benefit of our affiliate owners and our
gym owners to get more people into the
gyms our job CrossFit HQ call it we need
to be telling the world all of these
things on a regular basis I truly
believe that we're not I would say doing
a great job of it right now I hope to
work with our team to get us to a better
spot where we are letting the world
everyone know how safe it is and how the
how good the trainers are and we have to
do a better job of making the trainers
better we have to help the Affiliates
become better because we have to let the
world know that it's a great training
option because it really is and it's for
anyone and everyone I don't want to
sound like I'm trying to pitch it but
I've just lived it for the last 20 years
but I am because it's um
it's the most effective training
protocol out there and one of the things
we've done is we've demystified training
and what I mean by that is
this uh this notion of training being
for these uh called the nsca coaches and
and these Olympic weightlifting coaches
that are that are on a pedestal like you
these movements are complex but they're
accessible to all of us you can do them
I can do them he can do them our kids
can do them they just need to be trained
in them and they just need to um have
proper instruction the funny thing is I
was telling this to um one of the
captains I met with recently um on in
Fort Stewart actually in Fort Bragg I
said the the deadlift the squat the
cleaning jerk the snatch for soldiers
should be just like how to break down
your M4 and what I mean by that is the
points of performance for all of those
movements they should learn through
their training at every stage of
training how to identify good movement
and how to perform good movement and how
to correct good movement just like they
learn how to break down and service at
M4 now that's a foundation of knowledge
they should have and then you have
experts you have strength and
conditioning coaches just like you have
armors that when you need a little more
help or you want to need more knowledge
you take your gun to the armor if you
want to learn more about programming or
learn more about movement you go to the
strength and conditioning coach so
there's a there's a world where we need
to educate the soldiers more on these
movements and that plays back out to
just this General concept of the general
public these are things that everyone
should be doing and they're not hard to
uh hard to learn or hard to do once you
have good instruction in coaches
now
CrossFit last I guess it's been two
years you've mentioned a couple times
you got fired uh there was a like uh I
guess an entire Paradigm Shift inside a
CrossFit
um Greg Glassman who founded it he
he's like a I I I've met him before I
don't I can't even say I really know him
I mean I but you know just knowing about
him he was kind of like this libertarian
to the core kind of guy
spoke his mind to a fault I would say
and the reason I say that because some
people like oh you can't do that you
should speak your mind well
if you speak your mind and it creates an
outcome that you didn't really want then
maybe speaking your mind you could have
done a better job
uh but you know that kind of stuff got
him into trouble yep um
CrossFit at some point left social media
completely
uh and and just he be it seemed like he
became increasingly
like outspoken about political issues
and about things that
you know honestly I was looking through
some of the stuff that he would say and
I was like this is
you know I like to talk about simple
clear concise communication that people
understand it wasn't always right it was
always stuff like what does that
actually mean what are we trying to say
here
it ended up not working out good for him
yes
um Greg had a way of communicating that
where you talk about simple clean clear
communication Greg had a way I said that
wrong good night simple clear concise
yeah simple clear concise Greg had a way
of um
not doing Simple clear concise
communication by Design kind of to let
uh kind of make you think and go what
did he just say and have to peel layers
back because he was so intelligent and
he he's a mad scientist genius
um he did that deliberately and yes kind
of at the end of the day that did catch
up with him because he
um
in the Tweet he what he said was
definitely
misunderstood by what his intent was
with it and it got him in a lot of
trouble and a lot of his Concepts were
um he had to dive in a layer deeper to
really understand what he's trying to
say but but he didn't have he didn't he
didn't want to dumb his talk down he
wanted to elevate his speech and let
people kind of come up and figure it out
and one one approach I'm not going to
say was right or wrong but that's the
way he he liked to do it he liked to
communicate
so he communicates himself out of a job
kind of
um uh you actually became CEO for what a
month something like that yeah like a
month and a half at that point he hadn't
he had not sold the company and so he he
did the Tweet gotten a lot of uh trouble
over that and then um ended up stepping
back still on the company put me in as
CEO and
then there was some other stuff that
started coming out and more attention
was drawn to him they piled on him and
then he um there's a lot more pressure
to sell there's actually a phase where I
think had this second round of attacks
not come at him had it just been the
original tweet that he would have had a
better chance
um call it surviving as owner with me as
CEO and then getting out on the other
side but the Second Barrage of of
college
attacks really
just got him to a place where like okay
I'm gonna sell this thing and he he put
a number out there internally or not
even to the team but amongst himself and
his inner team and someone met it and so
he ended up selling the company and when
he sold it that that team who bought it
the guy who led the effort to buy the
team was like Hey I'm putting myself in
a CEO I'm like yeah I get it dude he
just bought the company so like I had no
once I knew there was talk of selling
going on I had no like aspirations to
fight for the position or to like I'm
gonna stay here regardless because I'm a
realist I knew what that represented
so that guy comes in
this uh
the company buys the company company
buys CrossFit they put in this new CEO
he didn't last that long either right I
mean how long was he there for
maybe a year and a half
um if that he I don't remember the exact
timeline but um
he ended up firing me and then shortly
after that he um he left and then
shortly after that I came back
[Music]
and you know uh
for me a lot of this drama stuff this is
for lack of a better word drama I know
it's your life right I hate to just like
paint it as like oh it's just a bunch of
drama and it is a bunch of drama like
that's what it is it's freaking drama
and I the whole time I was kind of like
looking at it
thinking it's a lot of drama but still
it's kind of because again I'm sitting
here with a CrossFit gym that I've had
for 15 years it's like where is this
going yeah and I
you know I'm not a very I don't I don't
overreact to things I kind of let things
play out and see what's going to happen
and and finally you you know as this new
CEO came on board
um Don how do you say his last name fall
fall down fall comes on board he
actually went to the Naval Academy with
life who wrote this book with me and
another book with me is and he was in
the Marine Corps
he he worked in a bunch of like you know
tech companies as a legit like business
guy with military background with
leadership experience
and that kind of gets it to where it is
now like like right now it seems as
though
honestly for the the most I've seen
um and I think you know when you talk
about Glassman I think his approach like
you talked about his approach with like
Communications he also had a weird
approach with leadership you know like
oh yeah it was like Hey we're gonna like
uh almost again I said libertarian but
that was also applied to
to the leadership like oh if you're good
you're good and your gym will do good
and if you're not then your gym will
fail and that's the way and it'll hey
you know the brand will live on because
the bad people will fail in the good
when maybe there's a better way to do
those things like you're talking about
like if someone's a shitty trainer yep
we shouldn't let him have a gym if the
gym is not have a certain standard we
shouldn't let it be there but he didn't
do that yeah so now see so so to me I
was always kind of you know again I've
got my own gym here I'm doing my thing
which is kind of also in line with that
attitude like Hey we're right we're not
following your protocol like I got my
own gym like we're we're doing how we're
gonna do it so I was kind of okay with
that not thinking about the fact that if
you've got someone that's a knucklehead
running a gym it can be problematic
either the brand a bad name but that was
his attitude
I would say now
I think
uh
it is a high point for me from my vision
of CrossFit over the last however many
years it's been in 15 years for me is
that right there's been 25. it's been a
long time that I've been around uh
um yeah I guess it's 15 or 16 years this
is the time it seems like the the
clearest vision
the best quality the unified goals it
seems like things are as good as they
have ever been for CrossFit right now
I I believe things are really good for
CrossFit right now
um don don fall was a great hire by the
board a great decision in terms of just
someone who their background
specifically you know the Navy time or
I'm sorry the Naval Academy and then the
Marine Corps time and then what he did
after that in the Silicon Valley he
checked a lot of boxes and he what I
mean by that is like here's someone that
definitely
um can relate to a lot of the staff a
lot of the people like myself who have
military backgrounds a lot of our
community is you look at our roots and
our history it kind of is This
counterculture seal-like movement in the
beginning that grew to much more than
that but having someone with his
experience in this role
showed an awareness and appreciation for
where we've been and who we are that is
powerful and since he's been here yeah
he's done a really great job in terms of
bringing our team together kind of
galvanizing our mission and giving us
Clear Vision he he is a much different
leader than Greg I would say Greg wasn't
even a leader at times he he was a
leader of a movement but
um I mean to be honest we he and I we
are good friends we're still friends to
this day I talk to him on a regular
basis we had a complex relationship we
had a wild ride together just as as
friends and as a business or as boss and
employee
um
his style and my style or our style of
leadership was very different and um and
that caused problems at times and even
some of the crazy things he did in the
past
um with like the social media and some
of those things you talked about you
know like
um to say that the team was on board or
to say that there were things that we
were doing as a company or things that
he was saying as a company that we were
supporting and on board with and bought
in on it would I would be lying if I
said that I mean he and he was he was
the sole owner and so people would
always tell me that he's a sole owner so
he can do whatever he wants that was
true and he did yeah and uh and I and
the problem with that too is a lot of us
because it was such a public it's not
your local
um Construction Company you know what I
mean it's a global brand that
represented a lot of employees
represents a lot of Affiliates and so
the things he did at times was
definitely in
let's call it isolation of of a lot of
the team members being on board yeah
when you mentioned the like the SEAL
Teams counterculture the the rebel
nature which is absolutely true that's
that's part of Who We Are
but what I saw and I'm sure you saw this
too the change and the
professionalization of the SEAL Teams as
we grew and as the war
continued and as we got bigger and as we
had more people and as we had more
visibility we had to become more and
more
professional yep and it seems like
that's that's what the transition is
happening now and has been going on for
the last you know six months to a year
with Crossfit and and I'll tell you what
it's been awesome for me
um you know we I I was actually trying
because we have
been talking with Crossfit and Jocko
fuel for like the last I don't know
that's what I was trying to figure out I
don't know where it started at some
point
there was well when I saw you at Bobby's
Memorial right you had mentioned that
you guys were talking and then I dug in
with our team and at that point it was
early in the uh early stages of
development yeah and I the the
connection was so natural right like
like here we have Jocko fuel we we make
supplements to make you perform better
we make protein we make energy drinks we
make like that's what we do and I here I
am had a CrossFit gym since 2007 like it
it
CrossFit to me as I mentioned was
something that was always trying to
benefit the world and make people better
and I've gotten a bunch of people to do
CrossFit over the years and
to to try and make them better and Jocko
fuel is the same thing like we're here
we are trying to help people optimize
their performance in whatever realm that
they're in and so you have this real
obvious kind of
unified attitude at both companies of
like hey we got two companies that are
trying to help people get better and um
I thought that was cool and again I'm
not exactly I don't know who reached out
to who first I don't think it was I mean
I don't know where it came from and I
remember my if they would ask me this
two years ago two years ago I would have
been like hey man like I don't know
there's a lot of there's a lot of
polarization around it there's a lot of
people that that hate on it and a lot of
negative feelings about it and there's a
lot of positive feelings too and we're
gonna end up in this weird world uh but
but since the timing was good and I'm
looking at where everything's at and I
see the progress being made for me it
was like the perfect time for
to kind of join forces pretty awesome
yeah we're definitely uh the last few
years we've been on our heels and maybe
even before the last two years what I
mean by that is just um working to pull
ourselves up
um specifically the last two years after
the the Glassman
um after the Tweed incident but even
before that we had shut down our social
media we had shut off a lot of our media
creation and when you think about at
that time as a longtime affiliate owner
you're an affiliate owner other
affiliate owners what value or what is
CrossFit doing for me if we're shutting
off our Mega mouthpiece our Mega areas
to communicate with the world the safety
and efficacy of the program
and and we're not doing that anymore
then what are you doing you're just
taking my money and putting or letting
me use the name and that there became a
point when that wasn't enough and so
yeah the the whole shutdowns of the
social media was not on not a fan of and
I did not think that did any favors and
it and then obviously the transition and
that phase we were just clawing our way
back and now you are right it is it
feels like we're in a much better place
and an area to uh to grow on and expand
from
when I was fired we talked about this
briefly I uh I lived it out publicly and
that was a weird like just like what I
mean by that is like everybody knew it
wasn't like I worked for again that
construction company example a
construction company it's I got fired
and I had to you know I could go home
and deal with it however I wanted but
like the whole CrossFit World knew and
that was interesting it was
um I definitely wish I could get fired
and not have the whole world have to
know again if that ever happens again
but I think those days are gone
um so being in this position in this
with this call it Spotlight it's
um
it's a burden I mean not a burden but
it's like it's a weight it's like you
know I I don't mean a burden in how I am
or how I act because how I act or how I
am is consistent and the same regardless
of if I was popular in the community or
not popular how I work and how I conduct
business is the same but there's this
extra weight of like
um the eyeballs the the attacks and I
didn't cover this early but in terms of
the attacks like
way early on I just stopped looking and
I drew a couple rules for myself with
social media early early on one I was
never going to comment so even to this
day on any of my platforms I don't
respond to anything I just feel like
it's a slippery slope and two
um
early early on there was a bunch of
haters and that had blogs or whatnot and
they'd come after us and one of them I
forgot which one it was he posted
something and my wife at the time or
she's still my wife but at the time she
was training at CrossFit Coronado and he
had pulled the picture from the website
from their website of her training and
posted it and went after her form but
didn't cite her name or didn't say it
was but he was coming after CrossFit and
us with an image of her and I was
pissed off and I didn't know if
he must have known and he was doing that
to get at me but at that point I was
like I will never put my family out
there and that's another thing I've had
like this wall of like I don't post
pictures of them or with them I don't um
because I don't want to have to deal
with anyone saying anything and how it's
going to make me react to that so the
best way I can handle it is just nope
they're not out there and I keep the
private part of my life completely
private and so what I do put out there
or what I do show is super deliberate is
super thought through it's uh it's not
by accident I've actually I have a
second
um
I have another Instagram account I don't
even use my main one that much anymore
where because I'm into shooting as I
mentioned I just post hunting and
shooting stuff and it's like hey if
you're into that stuff you can go watch
me do that and see that there and I
don't even have to put it on my main
account because
um that stuff obviously is is polarizing
so and let me rephrase that
I don't put it out in a polarizing way
like I'm not like posting stuff and
talking about the Second Amendment or
talking about any of these issues going
on I just
um post videos of me doing my passion
what you like to do and what I like to
do yeah yeah it's funny because
like I I only I I
from my perspective like oh I saw you
got fired but like that was it there's
no it was no drama for me yeah yeah
right I'm watching you get fired but the
the thing that was kind of weird for me
is like I I've known you I guess now
we've confirmed since 2007. yep
um
you didn't I was just a random team guy
I wasn't like some like author or social
media person I was just a normal dude
and since day one you were just like
cool uh like I remember you'd say oh you
want to come to this thing I'd email you
once every three years it's funny you
say that that's what someone asked me
like how do you know Jocko I I'd say I'd
responded with every few years he emails
me asking for a spot for a seminar for
one of his trainers yeah once every
three years that email him to be like
hey bro I hope everything's cool yep uh
I see there's a level one cert in San
Diego I need to get recertified you'd be
like yup you're in yep that was it no no
reason and this was when either I was
still in the teams and was just you know
like you had no reason to do this other
than you're just a good dude that was
just trying to help the brother out
right and so that's my been my
interaction with you and then I'd go and
you know I'd see you there and you'd be
like hey what's going on we talked about
whatever and then carry on yeah it
wasn't like well he hasn't called me in
a while like you had every you actually
see I'm not because I'm a I'm I don't
communicate with people yeah like I
don't respond to people like I don't I
don't have a bunch of uh uh you know I
don't you're not gonna hear from me on
your birthday like that kind of thing
and so I would reach out to you like hey
I need to go to this thing or hey can we
send a guy to that and you're like cup
cool all done yep again for no reason
other than just like we met you seem
cool I guess I seem cool we're
considered each other to be cool we're
good yep and that's so when I would see
people like getting I saw people like
getting crazy about you I was like bro
what is what is going on and you know I
I think that just um I guess that's a
little bit of the nature of the beast
when you're in a position like you're in
people are gonna find things to attack
and and look for reasons to try and
bring you down and bring down what
you're doing
um I guess that's part of the joy the
fitness the fitness is polarizing in its
nature oh that's true right Fitness and
Nutrition right well this Fitness and
Nutrition but this specific CrossFit
this style of Fitness is even polarizing
within Fitness and then you find someone
in it Greg or myself at the top and
people who are leading it and then they
become easy targets because you just
don't want to attack the brand you want
to attack the people you know what's
funny about all the people that attack
us too it's like um I don't like well I
don't like bodybuilding for one but you
will never find me on any bodybuilding
sites or any bodybuilding forums talking
about bodybuilders otherwise Echo
would be calling you out
you know what I mean so like for yoga
I'm not a yoga fan although I will say
big picture I appreciate both of those
activities for people being in them and
being fit and trying to change their
lives but my point is it's a unique
person or a special person who doesn't
like something and then goes over to
their pages and goes over to their
forums and starts blasting it it's it's
a horrible person actually is what it is
yeah that's definitely not a good way to
go through life you know as you're as
your fourth grade teacher told you and
your dad told you and your mom told you
and your principal told you if you don't
have anything nice to say don't say it
man yep and that proves to be true
um
we got
this little
collab going I guess chocolate Fuel and
Crossfit that's what we got going on uh
hey if you have a gym a CrossFit gym and
you want to carry Jocko fuel you can
email JF sales at jocoofuel.com
uh we're doing some if you want to try
Norco fuel
we're doing uh like a
there's terms in the in the retail world
of selling buy one get one at fifty
percent off jockoffuel.com and free
shipping over 99 bucks we're trying to
introduce people to what we've got going
on
um we got a bunch of product for you
guys to try but that's because
I want you to get better I want you to
go to the gym I want you to eat clean
that's what I want you to do
I think Dave wants you to do the same
thing you got a lot going on we got a
lot going on you also do clothing right
yeah we have uh we have a clothing
company shoes 100 made in America we got
we make boots right now
um we make you know jeans Jiu Jitsu Keys
rash guards shorts hoodies
uh I'm working on something not to the
level you have but I'm working on
something right on awesome yeah
um well I look forward to whatever
you're working on does this does this
get us to tell you olive oil olive oil
olive oil oh sweet right on I've been
saying that for years and uh you got
guys in CrossFit selling coffee you got
guys selling um there's even some people
that sell alcohol wine beer whatever
um I'm like no one in our space is
selling something as clean and pure as
olive oil I'm in let's talk after we get
done yeah for sure I'm in 100 where
um I want in on that that's what I do uh
does that get executive speed where
we're at right now yeah absolutely
um we're excited we're excited to be
working with a brand like yours it's
been years I think in the making and as
you said it's the right time
it's an awesome time
um
Echo yes sir do you have any questions I
do bodybuilding questions no we'll skip
that one so when you're in the Navy you
can have another job or is that like an
exception I don't get it usually no well
I know enough we know another guy that
did that and I was all confused I was
like wait how are you still in the Navy
if you're you literally have like this
company in this job or whatever like so
what's the what's the deal then it
depends at What occasion and sometimes
you have to be really formal and get
like written permission all the way up
to your CEO and and oftentimes if I was
not at that role I had there was no way
it could have been done like if I was at
a regular Seal Team where I was
deploying and training I could not have
done the role unique time unique
circumstance unique leadership that
allowed me to so so it's essentially
what you can get away with with varying
degrees of officiality kind of a
scenario yeah that sounds about right
yeah it and it's almost it's always
going to be on the not to interfere
basis right in other words no matter
what happened
this Navy job is the absolute priority
so you got to be careful now it makes
sense yeah cool man great to meet you in
person yeah nice to meet you too right
on uh crossfit.com is where you can find
out about CrossFit you can find it on
Twitter Instagram Facebook at CrossFit
Dave you're on Instagram you're on
Twitter now the one I know is the Dave
Castro yep that's my Instagram that's
the one that's the big one and then I
have the hunting one which is uh at TDC
hunts at TDC the Dave Castro hunts yeah
uh and you got CrossFit ranch.com yeah
yeah we have crossfitranch.com too where
people can sign up for drop-ins to go
work out at the ranch which is a pretty
cool people who travel do that a lot
yeah that sounds pretty cool it's a
pretty cool site yep one more question
yeah if I go to the CrossFit Ranch can I
do a bodybuilding routine you can thanks
bro
I got this guy you can ask this guy he
does Matt cons now yeah that's all from
me he used to just be just nothing but
curls and you know what I did his I did
his bicep he's got a bicep routine I did
it today I did it today you know we're
gonna work out those buys a little bit
uh awesome man Dave any closing thoughts
now thank you for having me on this was
a pleasure well um honored and I'm
enjoying your book oh thanks man and uh
thanks for coming down thanks for
sharing your experiences thanks for
sharing your Lessons Learned and um most
important thanks for your service to the
teams to the country I know you don't
talk about it but
um I know it's serious service and
sacrifice so thank you for that and
thanks for what you continue to do today
to go out there and try and help people
become
faster and stronger
and fitter which helps them with every
aspect of their life that is appreciated
thank you thank you
and with that Dave Castro has left the
building Echo yes you did not get to go
as deep into bodybuilding as especially
he kind of came at it too a little bit
he literally said he didn't like
bodybuilding no he said he respects it
as uh no he said he didn't like it at
first
sure and then I think I don't think he
said he said he respected yoga I think
no bro I think he respects yoga without
respect bodybuilding he said I'm not
down for bodybuilding but I don't go uh
hate on him in their forms okay cool
cool have you ever been to a
bodybuilding Forum on the interwebs no
disappointing I don't think I figured
you'd be all up in there I don't spend
much time in forums to say the honesty
Jack yeah they seem like they might be a
place for negativity maybe I don't know
well that's what it seems like yeah free
uh free for all well I know that Fitness
as a space if you will Fitness I don't
care CrossFit bodybuilding uh functional
fitness Fitness power lifting
the whole gig
um is a very uh like competitive real
like it's controversial
like yeah like if there's gonna be some
controversy that comes out they're gonna
they're gonna talk about it they're
gonna hate on it they're passionate
there's gonna be a lot of passion in the
top yeah there's a lot of different
approaches to Fitness and there's a lot
of different approaches to different
goals within Fitness as well so like how
you kind of started to talk about diet
okay Fitness diet how to raise kids
political stuff and religion five that's
the big five we call them the big five
is that is that your big five or is that
a more known Big Five it's a known Big
Five not called the big five Big Five is
something else but it's called five
topics to avoid it Thanksgiving dinner
religion okay hold on slow down religion
okay yep that can be some controversy on
that diet okay yep there's definitely
controversy around that exercise for a
little while in my life
my wife
told me don't talk about diet with her
friends all right she was correct this
is in the old school days I was ahead of
the curve yep she would be like just
don't can you
okay so we got real diet religion
politics
politics certainly Fitness Fitness yes
sir how to raise kids interesting yeah
I'm gonna say that's probably awesome so
yeah if there's gonna be some drama in
any uh industry
and you select one of those Industries
you can there's a high likelihood that
the drama is going to be Sky High yeah
and look there's drum this is what you
know we we talked about and I I didn't
mean to
diminish the drama
that that Dave you know actually lived
through but from my perspective it is it
was a bunch of drama like you know I'm
watching it's like geez what are these
people going crazy attacking each other
and all this stuff so the good thing is
and as I said
if they would have come if we would have
started talking two years ago like Jocko
Fuel and Crossfit I would have not been
too fired up for it and who knows what
they would have been I don't know but
I'm just saying from my perspective two
years ago three years ago it's like
there's a lot of Mayhem going on yeah
but they certainly
have moved and are I think they're in a
much more positive place right now
um and
I think it's going to be awesome because
CrossFit is a gateway
to Fitness for so many people so many
people and I think that's gonna be
awesome I think that people hearing
about it more is going to get more
people to go and try it I think the fact
that they've gotten better as coaches
and as instructors is going to be
beneficial to everybody
and yeah I'm looking forward to see
where this goes we got I mean the stuff
that we're making right now to a Jocko
fuel is like gonna be so beneficial we
got I'm gonna drink I'm actually
drinking some hydration right now have
you tried the hydrate yet hydrate Taco
hydrate I got my first one today
do you tried it today oh you haven't
even mixed it up yeah that's coming June
9th June 9th I think is when is when the
hydration's coming out it's
it's awesome we got time War we got
joint Warfare we got uh the protein
cookies we got Peach we got so many good
so much good stuff that we're coming out
with right now you know what I think is
going to be
and I was talking to Jason calipa do you
know that yeah I was talking to him the
other day and he's because he's got a
couple like CrossFit Gyms and he advises
a bunch of people and he's a former
CrossFit Champion he's like yeah the
ready to drink protein yeah
and the go to to it's the same it's it's
such a good combo to go oh I'm going to
do the activity go right I'm done with
the activity I need to recover
this is my protocol now by the way and
having like here not Victory MMA
when you can just get done and you're
walking your car and you're drinking a
monk yep you feel the goodness when I
crack a go like I walk to my eyes I'm
walking I have a is this bougie to have
a beverage refrigerator in your house
yes okay I I am admitting to a level of
bourgeoisie I have a beverage
refrigerator in my house that is filled
with beverages those beverages are go
and Mulk just beverages just beverages
it is that's good though but that's what
I have yeah but when I'm going to come
to the gym I'm walking I go bash my
beverage refrigerator my bourgeoisie
beverage refrigerator and I get a go and
I open it and I drive here and it's like
it's the perfect
time and then I get here get changed by
the time I'm stepping on the mat I feel
it I have the exact same protocol well
essentially where yeah I actually can't
really go anywhere that's that takes
more than 15 minutes without bringing a
go pretty much like there are very few
exceptions we went someplace me in the
fam go come down to train today go yeah
all day you know what's another
I don't know you call it a sleeper I
don't even think it's a sleeper the
greens
the greens are good this is the thing
well greens aren't known to be good
these are known to be bad greens is the
kind of like hey look I don't want to
eat a bubble butt roughage you know in
real life so I'm gonna take a a cool
like legitimate supplement but you gotta
understand it's just like
it's just a bunch of greens kind of
mashed up and it's like yeah that's it
but they're not known for Taste that's
the thing so it's like okay if you're
gonna rough it at least rough it just
for a little while so it's like yeah
we're gonna go through it cool we've all
accepted that that was kind of the the
original protocol they you know they'll
be like hey what should we tell people
about the grains this is me imitating
everyone else's voice yeah it's the
combination of Joe Moss of Pete of Brian
of all them that when I combine all
their voices together they sound like us
hey what do you think
so they'll say like hey what do you
think we should what's a good thing to
say what should we tell people about
green and I go hey tell people your
greens don't have to taste like dirt
yeah how's that perfect Your Greens
don't have to taste like dirt tell them
that because because greens taste like
dirt yeah no reason for that yeah
there's no reason for that dirt and Moss
like dessert yeah for sure and you know
when you're a little kid let's face it
you were looking at a piece of moss it
looked like it might taste good right
that's how we know what dirt Moss tastes
like yeah exactly and then for some
reason people thought just because you
ate it when you were five you're still
gonna gut through it no no reason for it
no greens Peach greens anyways that's
what's going on we uh have a little
partnership that we formed up with
Crossfit so
if you're gonna start doing CrossFit
you're gonna need to feel yourself get
yourself some choco field jockle
fuel.com go check that out like I said
we gotta we're doing a little special
to welcome the crossfitters out there
into the fold buy one get one fifty
percent off
free shipping over 99 bucks that's a big
deal
because shipping can cost a lot
but if you buy more than 99 bucks then
you're good to go so there you go go
check that out jocklefuel.com also check
out originusa.com
because originusa.com
we have stuff that's made in America and
there's a lot of people right now in the
world that are pro human rights
and let me ask you this have you met
anyone that's pro-slavery no well no
okay I have not I have not met another
human in my lifetime that was
pro-slavery yeah and yet there's slavery
right now yeah there's slavery right now
that's true and I can tell you where it
is
it's if you look at the tag on your
clothing
and it says made in China
they might as well say
made by chained people because that's
what's going on over there
uh don't do that don't support slavery
support don't support
um environmental disaster which is all
when you have a factory in America
there's inspectors that come to see
what's happening to see what kind of
waste is coming out of your factory and
I'm talking about the factories that I
have there's inspectors that come and
you're not allowed to put certain things
chemicals into the ground or chemicals
into the air you're not allowed to do it
there's rules and regulations there's no
rules and regulations overseas they're
just dumping their chemicals into the
water into the air they don't care
so for all those reasons go to origin
USA and get yourself
a pair of jeans
by the way best jeans you'll ever get I
was going to say and just in case a
small chance comes around uh comes
around in your head that you care about
how uh how you look in some jeans
I throw in that reason as well or if you
care how you function yes sir because
you might be into the
fashion sure over on this side of the
table we're in the function okay there
you go there you go uh go to
originusa.com screw yourself some stuff
also also Jacques the door it's called
Jaco store
look we're on the path look whether you
do CrossFit Jiu Jitsu both
running lifting bodybuilding whatever
actually I'm gonna be on I don't know
that I do bodybuilding I I actually know
that I I will no no no wait wait wait
let's say this
your your CrossFit
modality sure includes bodybuilding
right Am I Wrong well let me think okay
so does shoulder press dumbbells
so if I did uh four sets of 15 with them
rest between bodybuilding oh two failure
or almost to failure that's bodybuilding
homes I mean I'll ask you that's
bodybuilding right what is the purpose
as you like to say why are you doing
that to make my shoulders strong
dumb ass off your shoulders strong is
there any concern about size
look am I going into the fight set to 12
kind of scenario wait what did I do 15
yeah you said 15. no hey look if they
happen to get bigger amen cool yes I
will because it's a win yes sir but I do
do deep squats yep I do do uh clean and
press yep good good as part of a met con
this is my routine by the way so hey man
hey I will say this I do bodybuilding
type exercises like tricep pull Downs
you do them curls curls I do those
things good why look do I do also do
cleans yes yeah
do I also do presses yes but
I found that keeping your like smaller
muscle groups also engaged is useful
yeah and let's face it
we want to have guns
let's go uh but yes okay good okay good
I do some bodybuilding movement I don't
do because you can consider the whole
routine in the spirit of all these
modalities as it were consider the whole
routine if it's a hybrid of bodybuilding
strength training Olympic lifting clean
and press clean and jerk as part of a
met con so that's an Olympic lifting
there's some CrossFit in there because
it's some stuff is for time sometimes
it's a amrap what's the s yeah yeah
sometimes it's that so there's something
in there kind of a thing and then um
what else would there be yeah the
bodybuilding stuff for sure so okay as a
comprehensive program what is that kind
of everything right which kind of makes
it CrossFit and then I do the genres
yeah and then what there you go but um
either way Hey look it's part of the
protocol it's part of the routine
same thing with the whole you know
nutrition diet exercise is part of the
whole routine it's part of the path
that's what I'm saying I see exactly
what you're saying back to Jocko store
if you want to represent while you're on
this path you see what I'm saying you go
to jackal.com Freedom it's true
it's an oxymoron or a hypo what do you
call it when it contradicts it call it
the truth yeah but it is true we also
have the shirt Locker which is a
subscription shirt scenario get a new
shirt every every uh every month
different designs some good good
feedback on that one uh subscribe to
that subscribe to this podcast subscribe
to Jocko underground.com we appreciate
your support we don't own this platform
unless you're listening on Jocko
underground we don't own the platform
that means they could be getting in
there and editing it out or removing it
Banning us
they might be banning us because we are
doing bicep curls no is that possible uh
Jocko that's Jocko underground.com go
check that out YouTube subscription uh
Jocko podcast official
origin USA go check out the video Pete
just put up we were able to give a raise
to everybody up there
at in Maine so go watch that video
you'll you'll see what I'm talking about
that's a that's an origin
uh origin USA YouTube also Jocko fuel
YouTube channel I want to know what's
going on inside Jocko fuel or what
that's more like not inside that's like
a with Jocko this is what we're making
right now so check that one out uh
psychological warfare Flipside canvas I
just talked to Dakota today Dakota Meyer
you know what he's doing he's getting
after it man and if you want to get
after it like Dakota go to
flipsidecamas.com check that out I got a
bunch of books that I've written you can
check out those books that I've written
also have a leadership consultancy
called Echelon front go to
echelonfront.com if you need leadership
inside your organization we will help
you out we do Live Events and they all
sell out we oversold our last monster we
had to like
the staff had to sit in the back corner
and all this stuff so we sell everything
out so if you want to go to one of our
Live Events go dashlandfront.com and
check out our Live Events also if like I
said if you have
problems in your organization those
problems
oh you how do you know what the problem
is causing the problems Draco you don't
even know what industry we are I know
it's causing the problems it's
leadership problems so if you want to
solve the problems in your team in your
organization go to echelonfront.com
and we will come and work with you we
also have a
we have an Online Trading Academy for
life
to interact with other human beings
you know if you want to interact with
other human beings
you you need to learn it it's not a
natural thing I was talking to Ty you
know SD Thai I do Sandy he used to be he
used to he's transitioned he was main
time but now he's become SD Thai I hear
a good thing so SD Thai I was talking to
him and he you know he was talking about
having conversations with people and how
he's starting to become aware of oh
these are the things that I've heard you
talking about and now I can see them and
I can detach enough to make sure that I
am taking the right approach yeah that
is what you learn on Extreme
ownership.com how to interact with other
people how to converse with them how to
ask Earnest questions how to see their
point of view how to influence them how
to allow yourself to be all these things
are in there
a little bit of magic
I was gonna say Bray you made such uh
the other day he made a good point where
you're like hey if you know how to if
you're doing all this stuff or whatever
imagine how and I think it made me kind
of go down this little whatever
psychological where and you're right
it's same as Jujitsu same as Fitness
lifting weights it's the same as like
reading even something that's
fundamental as reading imagine if
you were the only one who knew how to
read right now just all of a sudden or
let's say you were only one of like
eight people in the whole wide world or
whatever they know how to read you know
how how easy things would be for you
compared to everybody else you're the
only person that knew how to do Jiu
Jitsu Jitsu if you're the only person I
knew how to do an overhead Squad but you
would go challenging people to go
overhead squat contest well let's say if
you were the only person who lifted
weights and ran and and did good
nutrition first everyone else just ate
the normal stuff didn't lift at all
you know how much stronger it would be
it'd be easy life would be easy for you
in a way just walking around ruling the
planet it's it's kind of the same it is
the same thing yeah it's a little it's
the same thing it's actually what's
different is if if I know Jiu Jitsu
powerful skill to have powerful scope if
I know it when do I get to use it right
you're right I get to use it if you want
to use it with me and you come to my gym
or if we happen to be in the streets and
you happen to assault me
maybe I get to use some Jiu Jitsu
if it's strength training maybe a car is
on top of a baby and I get to lift it up
right maybe
We're not gonna set that up on purpose
but this
extreme ownership.com this is daily
interaction with other human beings this
is figuring out what you need to do to
maneuver correctly through life so that
you can build relationships where your
life is moving forward and getting
better rather than moving backward and
getting worse
that's simple it's a real simple
question
when has it been good that you had an
antagonistic relationship with someone
never like oh oh I don't like my boss
okay does it help you that that you're
fighting oh I don't like this peer of
mine does it help you that you don't
like each other I don't like the support
of mine does it help you that you don't
like each other yeah I don't like my
neighbor oh how does that work out
I don't like the garbage man okay well
how does that work out if you if you
have a good relationship with your
garbage man
guess what some of the garbage spills
out he runs out of the truck and throws
in he takes care of you bro that's so
true because I'm telling you bro you
ever see it I've seen those guys who
like come on let's face that garbage
truck sometimes it can be rough yeah oh
you're garbage like overflows and flies
inside he's not getting out of his trunk
right he has many more garbage things to
take care of no but when you line up
your cans correctly
and when you're out there like okay
maybe maybe once every other week you're
out there and you're helping
just give them a little help man you can
hear the garbage truck coming let's face
it get out there
we do that every once while you build
that little relationship all of a sudden
he's taking he's a little bit more
gentle with your kids then you're gonna
take him down to the city when they
break it's a problem
your whole life could be better that's
true so that's the kind of thing when
you start thinking about it you start
making every aspect of your life better
because you got a good relationship with
your garbage man you've got a good
relationship with your wife with your
kids with your peers with your boss with
your subordinates with the other team
over there the other department the
other division
they're like oh hey Draco what's going
on not much what's going on with you
awesome huh it doesn't have a big deal
it's true
just gonna make everyone's life better
yeah so go to extreme ownership.com
we'll learn a little bit of the magic
and if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their families gold star families check
out Mark Lee's mom mama Lee she's got a
charity organization if you want to
donate or you want to get involved go to
America's Mighty Warriors dot org and
also don't forget about Micah Fink who
is currently at this time apparently
last report
he was out in a field of rocks
and he was slinging rocks at waterfowl
and then swimming enough frigid Waters
to go recover them and eat them raw
he's helping veterans
relocate their soul
Heroes and horses dot org
and if you want to connect with us
Echo is at Echo Charles
I am at Jocko willink you can find
CrossFit at crossfit.com there on
Instagram Facebook Twitter they
re-engaged in those things they are at
Cross CrossFit and Dave Castro he's
Twitter at the Dave Castro and
also Instagram at the Dave Castro and
he's got that CrossFit Ranch and thanks
once again to Dave for coming down
sharing your lessons more important of
course
thank you for your service
in the teams and for our great nation
and thanks to everyone who has served or
is serving in the military thank you for
protecting our freedom and also thank
you to our police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emt's
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service and all First
Responders thank you for protecting us
and keeping us safe here at home
and everyone else out here
let me ask you something
what are you doing right now
right now
what are you doing
are you getting better or are you
getting worse
are you getting stronger are you getting
weaker are you building or are you
decaying
already becoming less capable or are you
becoming more capable
what are you doing
I'm asking you that question but you
need to ask yourself that question what
are you doing daily what are you doing
hourly
what are you doing this very second ask
yourself that question what am I doing
because there's a decent chance you
aren't doing anything productive
you're wasting time
and you're wasting your life and you're
wasting away do not let that happen
get control
take over
and go
now
and that's all we've gotten for tonight
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko
out